Just got your fugies up and I was like, that's all I need.
All right.
We're live.
I'm live now, too.
Now we're all live.
Oh, yeah.
Let me inform my chat real quick what I just said to them
like five minutes ago because I wasn't live.
So for those who are wondering why I didn't start at 4.30,
um, it's because Altair wanted to talk to his chat and Beto
forgot what time it was.
So he copied Altair's homework, but then I was like, Guys,
we're starting at five, guys.
So that's why they were 30 minutes early because Beto forgot
what time it was and he copied the wrong homework.
Wait, wait, wait, you weren't talking to your chat 30
minutes early?
No, I actually pushed it 30 minutes because I'm like, oh,
wait, I have more time.
I was like, you didn't want to talk to your chat, Beto.
That's fucked up.
And then I joined 120 seconds late.
So it was really just a beautiful song and dance I did
today.
We're starting off strong here.
Yeah.
um so do you guys know we're joining arc raiders in the
middle of a fucking war yeah we are yeah yeah okay so yeah
so i'll turn us to know the the the lord masters so he's not
lord masters so there is a apparently a giant ass war going
on with all the fleshies the flesh tubers um between two
different uh flesh streaming groups um wait no one of them
is a vtuber
Yeah, it's a peanut.
Peanut guy.
His name is literally burnt peanut.
I'm sorry.
I thought it was burnt potato.
Hey, if you're watching this burnt potato, burnt potato.
I like your name better as potato, but it's cool as peanut.
Baked potato.
Apparently today is the day where they're all going to war.
So good luck to us, I guess.
That sounds good.
grade are we supposed to avoid any specific math no i think
we're just i don't know wait no betto you know the lord
you're a better bigger lord master than me about this whole
arc reader thing what's going on um well i don't keep up
with any of that shit but i will say that they have
different it there it's just across it's like global it's
wherever you go if you're repin like the the colors of the
designated streamer uh you are like involuntarily part of
that team i have And they would go on the mic and be like,
so-and-so's team forever.
So-and-so's team forever.
I'm like, dude, I am not a part of this shit.
I am a complete third party.
I'm not.
I don't care.
I'm just trying to get some scraps.
I'm just like, are you new, brother?
I'm just going to kill you now.
So we're like, we're like rogues.
We're like rogues, like the outsiders then.
Yeah.
We're the non-affiliates called in war.
We're like mercenaries.
Oh, civilians?
Yeah, we're this.
We're civilians.
We're just civilians in a civil war.
Yeah, a bunch of marauders in this war.
Are there any colors that we have to avoid?
Yeah, what colors are we?
Oh, I don't know them at all.
I sure hope it's not white and orange.
Okay, it's fine.
It's fine.
Everything is fine.
Oh, they're like, would you like to update your graphics
card?
I was like, no.
Or your graphics driver.
Will you update it your driver?
You just believe them just like that.
Like, Doki, I'm a firm believer of NVIDIA, okay?
They just do whatever they want.
They can take my bios.
They can take my kernel, whatever they want.
They can pop it.
Damn.
Pop it.
Damn, you're so naive.
Did you guys start tutorial, by the way?
I did.
I'm level five.
Oh, okay.
Wait, you're level five?
Yeah, I did.
Actually, I didn't know there was a tutorial.
I thought.
I'll leave the tutorial to do.
You didn't even have it downloaded, Doki.
Come on.
No, I was so tired.
Oh, guys, no, you got to understand.
I have to link in.
Oh, thank you.
And thanks, Ben, for dropping by, too, for yesterday.
Wait, did you win?
Yeah, I won.
That's why I forgot to download Arc Raiders.
What the fuck?
Bro, I thought, bro, your luck strat, man.
Your luck strat infected my channel.
Is that what that is?
Yeah, you're giving your luck away, like, free money.
That's the only reason why we have meth guild.
We're just extracting luck from him every day.
We're extracting luck from him.
Okay, to link your- What's valuable currency there is.
Wait, Link existing account?
Oh, thanks, man.
Thanks.
I'm so fucking tired, bro.
Like, you know, like in competitive shooters, you got to
like think on the go and everything.
Oh, yeah.
And yeah, yeah.
And I was just like, you know, it's like they got counter
swapped like what they're playing in every fucking time.
And I'm so tired.
All the FOMO of not playing Marvel rifles.
It's really hitting.
And that's why I play one character.
Yeah, and that's why you get Target banned.
yeah i wouldn't have made it in that competition they know
my shit by now i would have been over yeah i think like one
of the players i was like it was like efa atha and i found
out that he spent because he he literally learned the game
like uh for it for in two days and i realized i looked at
his profile and all he did was play emma for like the entire
time yeah so then that's what i yeah i banned his emma i i
feel for him i feel for him and like the thing is he he was
their only tank player so i was like goodbye front line he
played for two days yeah i was like i had to do it i i was
guaranteed finals anyway and like they were our last match
and i was like no we gotta get clean sweep we got damn damn
leave no no thought no thought i was like we gotta get we
got three oh she's on her magneto arc all right let's see
here's a party okay we don't need to do party voice at all
clear that i'll do oh there's prox oh that's what you meant
the proximity voice yes yes uh you probably want to turn
that off yeah i'm gonna turn that yeah yeah if you want to
keep the vaude okay oh wait no oh i meant oh i oh no i
wouldn't it's fine i've had people say okay oter you will
lose the vaude I survived Counter-Strike, okay?
I'll survive this.
Don't worry.
You will not.
I guarantee you, you will not.
Wait, how many gamer words have you heard?
I just whisper.
Oh, it's like a dictionary for what I've played.
Oh, good thing is the learning.
Maybe we'll get lucky.
I don't know.
Yeah, maybe we'll get lucky.
Okay, the first, if I hear, okay, I'll have a quota.
If I hear five gamer words in this stream, I will turn it
off.
That's the quota.
Damn, five shit.
Okay, maybe you're good.
Yeah.
I wish we did.
just one run it's all five that's a limit five is the limit
okay it's gonna be like spread around you know throughout
yes a sprinkling of gamer yeah it's strengthening so it'll
be fine it's not like back and back and spice yeah you know
like a pinch of salt you know yes yeah oh it's not a pinch
of salt in this game it is yeah It's a salt mine.
Wait, but aren't people like cooperating?
Aren't people like super nice to each other in this game?
I've been seeing a lot of that.
In solos.
Yeah, in solos.
It's just a nice little, beautiful little thing you got
going on there.
But in trios, it's murder everyone you see and talk later.
Wow.
What happened to friendship?
I mean, we could try friendship.
We could try diplomacy.
We will be murdered.
We'll be like, what team are you on?
They'll be like, team, blah, blah, blah.
Like we're on that team too.
well we're not looking for colors yeah we just forgot the
colors yeah just be like oh we just forgot the colors you
know man i just don't have to unlock i was like oh sorry i'm
yeah i just i just didn't have it unlocked this is my first
day i'm learning how to sprint right now guys give me a sec
good good that's a very important very oh wait there's a
stamina bar it'll get you places way too realistic good old
chair also i don't know my sound guy is alive but like
please let me the volume is okay for my game i need a sound
guy yeah oh i don't you're my sound guy it's not good dude
how do i thank you what's the oh quick shift okay shift is
quick shift um terry played this before am i gonna have to
play teacher today yes i played yes it's your turn to coach
us oh what's with igl battle this week i don't want this yes
you do it's your you were born for this oh god no i am a
natural born follower if you no no no after that battlefield
experience you are meant to do this oh no your max luck man
you got me yeah you have max luck come on i'm just life in
it i just siphoned that luck out of your body like no like a
parasite you know like those angler fishes where like uh
we're like no no you like the angler fishes where like the
male becomes like a drained husk of a oh that's yes yeah
yeah wait You know the altar, right?
Okay, so like for angler, women angler fishes, like the male
angler fishes will attach themselves into the women angler
fish, and then it literally becomes a parasite and slowly
like drains their entire body until it's just like a part of
her.
It just becomes a sperm dispenser.
Yeah, yeah.
I wish I could just be a part of a different analogy, but
you know what?
That's great.
Rose, you can be your sperm dispenser.
Yeah, you're like the luck dispenser.
luck perfect perfect well oh my god we'll run with that then
oh my okay gav is battle the parasite yeah wait we are just
not going in with a positive outlook on gav's battle guys i
just realized i've reported myself okay arc raiders sense to
marvel rivals i need to confirm my sense real quick guys i
know exactly what upset you're using too yeah marvel rivals
arc raiders i'm on 800 dpi i use 10 sensitivity 24 point
okay what is 24 apparently it's 24.302 uh where is that do i
just have a really low sensitivity i don't know i mine my
marble rival senses 1.89 so there's no point 302 it's just
24 okay 24 there you go um all right here we go battle how
do you expect us to do you think we're gonna actually like
no yeah i expect uh yeah wait do you want the nice answer do
you want the real answer hey i'm saying our fraggers yeah y
'all y'all are probably fucked at least for the first few
hours I am the VTuber Cup Marvel Rivals oh shit I got shot I
got shot
well you know I've seen this in many different areas that
this game is very similar to Marvel Rivals so I think yeah
right the most similar game to it practically identical
almost like a hero shooter there's no other games that can
compare the Ark Raiders and the extraction shooter genre to
fly i agree i agree i mean maybe you guys will be fine you
could surprise me the only reason i say that is because i
was terrible at this game for like 30 hours and i have 50
hours how many hours you have wait wait i want to know how
many hours you have i have i have 50 hours in this game at
the 30 hour mark well hold on i'm still really bad so i i
don't really uh i don't really know how it's gonna go maybe
you guys pick up things faster than me but i'm not very good
at this game you've you're you have your battlefield though
your battlefield aim this is a boomer shooter i'm good at
boomer shooters that's like my thing well it's okay dude i'm
here i'll teach you oh wait i am slowly load in where am i
downloading items it's a body you're looting yeah but why do
the items slowly come up in the container you gotta look for
them no i opened the bag i should see everything She's an
entire Apex player.
This is way too realistic.
I don't like it.
I have drones shooting me.
That's the arc.
Do you guys want Laura?
Do you want me to leave that part out of the video?
Give me the Laura Master.
Give us the Laura Master.
That's the arc.
Oh.
So the drone?
Yeah.
And they are bad.
They are bad?
Why are they bad?
What did they do?
Yeah, what did they do?
Did they raid us?
No, we're raiding them.
Oh, oh, that's why they're called Ark Raiders.
Are they real people?
Or are they like...
Title drop.
Are they... Oh, we are in the stream right now.
That's kind of all I really know.
Ark bad.
I think they were made by rich people who live on another
planet, and they sent the robots to this planet to kill us
because we suck.
I'm not sure.
Why do we live here just looking for springs and like, yeah,
don't we just want food?
I think, I think, uh...
How are we bad if we're just trying to survive?
I don't think they like, uh, the rich people like us.
I think they want Earth back or something.
Oh, is it because we're poor?
Yeah, yeah.
Oh my gosh.
So they hate us because we're poor.
Yeah, this is so realistic.
Wait, I need, oh my gosh, I need heal myself.
Wait, how do I...
I don't actually know if that's...
a correct spark notes of the lore, by the way, before
everyone gets mad at me.
They steal your credit card information and then what else
do they do?
What else do they do?
Come on, battle.
Come on.
You're the only person that can help us here, man.
Enlighten us.
I'll be right back.
Oh, do you think he'll come back?
You know, last time you did this, he...
Do you think he'll come back?
Maybe a couple of hours.
Days, years.
Battle.
Guys, I don't think you'll come back, guys.
Anyone who's watching from Battle stream, please check out
Tara and me out because we'll still be playing.
Yeah, and then we won't leave you like Battle did.
Yeah.
So you guys should check us out.
He won't leave you on the play screen you know with me yeah
yeah yeah we have stuff actually going on on our screen so
check out dokeybird at youtube.com and only dokeybird at you
who i want to be you guys should follow redis altair
underscore hollow stars underscore en on twitch wait all
right what do i want to be if i'm a woman do you think
they'll shoot me But you're a woman.
I'm back.
You're a woman.
I'm sorry, I'm not a little boy.
No.
You know, if you, like, actually type on Twitch that you're
12, Twitch will automatically be bad.
It will automatically if you type in someone's chat that
you're 12 on Twitch, your account gets instantly banned and
you need to send them a picture of your ID to prove that
you're not actually 12.
What the fuck?
Yeah, you didn't know that?
I feel like the people who get in trouble for that should
get in trouble for that.
Why would you type like a 12 in chat?
Because you have to be 13.
Okay, so...
Okay, this...
Okay, what colors are you guys wearing for your outfit?
I'm red.
All right, what are you, Altair?
White and red.
You chose...
Did both of you choose red?
We got to spread the colors out in case like...
Wait, I'm changing.
Okay, I'm also white and red.
All right, I'm yellow.
Okay, so I'll tell you, you should be blue.
I'm blue.
You should be blue.
Yeah, you should be blue.
Okay, there you go.
All right.
We're good.
So one of us will survive for the war.
One of us will survive.
Or two.
Actually, no.
One of us will survive or two or one of us will die.
Can we have all three live?
I'm not gonna die.
We'll be fine, right?
Oh, this is a cool ass cutscene.
I'm watching a cutscene right now, guys.
Oh, hell yeah.
Yeah.
Whoa.
Did you guys...
I still can't believe this was made by the guys who did the
finals.
Yeah.
I never played that actually.
I guess it does kind of look a little bit similar, doesn't
it?
Yeah.
I guess like the models look very similar to the finals.
something is going on so they made that they have such a
good like back-to-back successes because I know the finals
is really popular in Asia and have a apparently a very
popular esports scene it's just I played it for a decent
amount it was a really fun game for the fun game yeah and
the people got too good at it as it goes that's like this
game oh no I don't like that it's hard I i i would just say
to recruits wait you guys oh look at the coloration there
nice oh i got that looks good yo look at us we're rgb that
looks cool without the oh why are you wearing a hat without
the g without the g we're rby yeah i forgot my colors guys i
don't even know what to bring i just i just click ready i'm
doing a free loadout oh we're like power rangers where you
guys are red oh i'm the red ranger yes oh my god i'm the
yellow asian ranger i'm the blue ranger all right let's see
i need to adjust my audio real quick together we make brown
ranger yay poop ranger let's see effects okay i'll stop
there yeah real mature man yeah that's so mature are for
mature audiences only for the adults that's right you don't
use the word poop you use the word no i use the word shit
that's right what no censors here no also to my sound guy i
lowered the sound effects oh thanks sound guy sound guy
thanks better is there friendly fire Where's Regis Altair?
Wait, where is he?
Don't shoot!
There's no friendly fire.
Oh, dude.
You're so friendly fire!
You're lying!
Oh, okay, nice.
It looks like it, though.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I want to lead you astray.
I shot you in the foot.
Hey!
What's up?
Don't shoot!
don't shoot let's learn the basics here yeah i'm sorry to
put your weapon away and run faster you hit h yep let that's
good to know or you can do the dancing do it do it don't do
that don't do that i don't want to see this this is a
serious game you guys this is a serious game with serious
consequences okay we can't be dancing do you wonder if like
some guy runs up and just sees all three of us, just try to
figure things out.
We're like, wait, why are you running away?
Why didn't you bring- You got to dance!
Beto, why didn't you bring your good loot?
Huh?
You don't trust us?
Yeah, come on, Bell.
Yeah, we're really good at this game.
Look at my gun.
It's a rattler.
Yeah, you said you've been playing for like 50 hours.
It doesn't look like you've been playing for 50 hours.
Where's my gun, man?
I said I was bad at this game.
so you must have extra loot why didn't you bring it i'd used
a free loadout yeah so you don't trust us wow you don't even
you don't trust us you don't trust it that's exactly right a
free load up because you don't trust everything we did um
the vtuber marble rivals champion and altair
that's true i was like you i was part of v psych you what
about you you're you're my plus one i brought you over
you're i don't want to be a plus one all right so what do we
do what do we do better well i'm happy you asked how the
fuck was i gonna say god damn it what was i saying no no
hang on no hang on hang on stop doing that dude it's hard to
think that way no you know like the little dance okay both
of you were freaking me out like trying to think let me get
closer no no okay okay yes i first of all i want to say i
got clocked immediately i did bring a free load out because
i know we're gonna get smoked in the first like number wow
not a believer not a i would i would you know there's
limited ammo how many boats you got yeah 130 yeah and how
many could how many per mag 10 yeah good luck
So guys, if you get shot in the battlefield, you're going to
want to hold down the Q button to activate your quick slot.
You see your quick slot?
Like this?
And there's something called a...
Wait, you said there's no friendly fight.
You friendly fight yourself.
But I thought that meant I don't get friendly fight.
That is not what that means.
You know that's what that means.
Oh, what are you doing there?
You did it!
I killed!
I did!
I did it, guys.
You healed yourself.
Yay!
Wait, my blood is bad.
How do I?
Look, I'm bandaging myself too.
Here we go.
Well, you've pretty much figured out the game.
That's it.
Wait, Drew's made it?
How did I make it?
Now we just loot and shoot.
Okay.
Loot, shoot!
Where do we go?
Better take us.
Well, if you look at your map, you can see these red
highlighted zones.
Those zones have high loot density of better items usually.
but they're normally hot zones for bad guys.
So where are the...
I'm a bad guy.
So where are they...
Where is the war, like, going on?
Like, we're...
A streamer war?
Yeah, we're...
That's just like by proxy.
It's just everywhere.
It's just generally in the game.
Like...
Is anybody at war right now?
Oh, hey, there's stuff here.
Are these good breaches?
Yeah, do you want to...
Do you want to...
Are you breaching that?
Yeah, you're about to get your first loot.
Oh my god, I got plastic and sensors.
Okay.
I'm breaching.
I'm playing Rainbow Six Siege.
Yep.
Your fuse.
It takes so fucking long to breach.
Breach.
Shouldn't I be stronger?
Not everything needs to be breached.
But it's like, I've been doing this for my whole life.
Shouldn't I be faster at breaching?
Like, why am I so weak?
Where's my muscle at?
Hey, using that, using a sledgehammer multiple times on a
giant, like, you know, computer structure, probably takes a
lot of energy, I'd say.
Nah, I got that.
Dude, I did that last night.
No, it's easy.
Yeah, it's easy.
Super easy.
It's like taking.
Are you going to shot at?
Oh, look.
Altair's encountered the ARC TM.
Wait, are they?
Oh, they're the drones.
It's the ARC.
That's the ARC.
Oh, are they?
Now you could watch out for the ARC.
Are they the PVE of the PVE?
Yeah, they're the PVE.
So you shoot their thrusters.
Good work.
You've killed the ARC.
We killed them.
We did.
Are you proud of us?
Oh, my God.
You searched their dead body.
You can search their dead bodies to get arc cells as well,
which you can then use to make shields.
I got an arc power cell.
How do I make the shields?
Thank you.
Well, you make it outside of the zone, but you can...
Can you make it for me?
Shut up.
Hey, shut up.
I unlocked crafting, but I still want you to make it for me.
I don't care.
It'll...
But we'll drag you down with us if you don't care.
It's okay.
I'll drag you down to the darkest piece of hell when I go
there.
Whoops.
I missed it.
Okay guys, now those arc power cells went in a pinch you can
equip them to your quick slot by hitting tab in the put them
in the quick use and they can be used as a shield
regenerator Just in case you get hurt and you don't have any
rechargers left Or you take them out with you and you can
you okay.
He's using one.
Okay, good work Wait, it gives him more shields.
How come he has so much more shields than me us?
He's using a medium shield better Wait, how did you find a
medium shield?
He's just better.
Okay, I'm just better.
He's just better better than bettle i'm better than maybe
i'm he's more better than bettle i never said i was good i
just have knowledge fun fact the red ranger was arrested for
wire fraud oh my god bettle what guys is that why you change
your name to michael my name's come on yeah he's trying to
hide from the feds right now he's trying to hide from the
irs right now that is true Wait, which part is on the run?
That's a fake identity and everything.
Try and keep up.
Yeah, yeah, I'll try and keep up.
I'm right here.
Wait, how are you like not wasting your stamina?
Oh, you're not running.
I'm not running.
I'm also way faster than you guys because I run for longer
because I'm a higher level because I put my stuff in
stamina.
Wait, we got you rank up.
Wait, we're not equal?
There's a skill tree.
No, we're not equal.
built equally life isn't fair we never will be equal you
understand yeah we're vtubers nothing's gonna be equal
that's the way the wasteland that's rule number one vtubers
are not equal in the wasteland but we're all poor we are all
poor but you've become less by getting garbage system and
we're all poor oh there's more arcs somewhere just poor no
no Oh, you know what?
Okay, guys, come here.
I'm grabbing some steel.
We're good.
Wait, we're...
Oh, there you go.
Something on fire, but we're good.
I'm here.
Okay, don't step in that.
Guys, these red lockers normally have pretty good stuff.
You might want to take a peek and see what you find.
Oh, I've got a ripped safety vest.
I love that restaurant.
Crude explosive.
What about the next one?
Silencer, ruined ice shields.
Let's say one for me.
A silencer.
Very good.
And those cards, you see the gem next to those cards.
That means it's a sellable.
You could sell it for monies.
Lots of monies.
Oh, I like money.
You're going to want to take all that shit.
That'll can you give me money?
My inventory is full now.
So should we leave?
I have a full last inventory.
I'll take all the loot.
Thank you.
Your inventory is full.
Well, Altair still needs to loot, right Altair?
Altair's legendary.
Thank you.
Wait, what?
Okay.
Thank you for the legendary modification.
What?
I found it legendary.
Yeah, yeah, what is the cause?
It's dropped right there.
What is that?
Wait what the fuck?
Wait, what?
Wait, I want to see.
Wait, wait.
Can I see this?
Wait, wait, wait.
I've never seen one of these before.
I want to see.
It's right here.
I opened it.
I have never seen a legendary before in my entire life.
Wait, thanks Beto.
You thanks for the luck Beto.
Yeah, thank you.
Thank you for the luck Beto.
Thank you You fucking talk UFO.
Thank you.
I appreciate you Guys I opened the box if anything came from
me Hey, the weird world when I opened the box though.
I had the box open when I Open the stupid box.
What else is in here?
Yeah, what the fuck was that?
Yay!
It's because I'm yellow.
Yellow for yellow.
No.
It was my finders keepers.
Dokey, can I have it back?
Dokey, dokey.
Dokey, you're not making me very dokey dokey right now.
Finders keepers.
I can't believe that just happened.
Fine.
I call next legendary.
Okay.
Well, guys, it looks like one of us has some really good
loot.
We should probably extract because we don't want to die and
lose that loot.
loot yeah we could just die well or we could just die it
depends do you guys want to leave or do you want to do you
want to secure the loot let's secure it okay let's secure it
what if i find two legendary lutes later i i can't believe
you found one i mean christ i've never seen that my entire
life you never got a legendary no and ever yeah that's maybe
you know how you said you max out luck maybe the luck just
goes to other people by like in interacting with you.
Maybe I get one in here.
Maybe I can.
Yeah, maybe you'll get one here.
We can grind his essence.
Guys, I hear gunshots.
Okay, those are people.
Those are bad guys.
Okay.
I'm a little scared.
Oh, wait, they're right here.
Jesus Christ, they're right here.
They're like close.
And we're fighting.
Oh, we're fighting.
Oh, and we're in a fight now.
There's no tutorial here.
Point at the enemy and shoot them.
Okay, okay.
I'll try my best.
I got Oh, you got shot at by the electricity thing to our
left One down one down.
It is one in front of it.
Yeah, I'm going back in I'm going back in those drones.
Yeah, yeah Oh my god a 10 gun.
Oh my god Michael The red watch out red ranger There's one
on me.
This one on me.
Okay, okay, okay.
You go you go.
I'm good.
Get the arcs Oh, no, there's one left.
He's right here on me.
Okay, okay I'm coming over.
Last one.
It's all you.
Oh my god.
I'm sorry.
Where is he?
He's being, the arc will fly to him.
I am getting shot by the arc.
I am.
You're lying.
Okay.
Take your time.
Just breathe.
You can also come to us.
If you want to try and get us up, you can also do that.
Okay.
I'm not good.
Just if you feel good.
Oh, fuck.
I'm dead.
The arc are here.
Get inside if you can try and, yep.
There you go.
Be careful.
This guy's around.
Well, if we die, we die.
If we die, we die.
We die, we die.
Good work, Doki.
Good work.
Thank you.
Watch out!
Behind you, shoot it!
Ah!
Why didn't you shoot it?
I have no bullets.
Maybe you should have been using them on me.
Watch out!
Christ!
Oh my god, you're right behind you.
I was red.
Whoa!
Well.
Well, it truly was our creators.
Go, go, go.
No, it's okay, it's in my safe pocket.
Whoa.
Wait, you were on a free loadout?
Yeah.
Nice.
It's in our safe pocket.
You guys can pick us up.
You guys can pick up.
Well, then technically, that was a huge success.
Yay!
We won.
dark raiders that was basically the entire crash course in
about five minutes that feels that was it hey battle thank
you for the gifted legendary item yeah thank you yeah you
don't know i'm right here they're trying to find me somebody
come get her whoa no one knows i'm right here we might die
i'm gonna die here so then they can't get get my that's what
you do oh Wow.
You learn quick.
If they don't know I'm here.
So they don't get our leads.
Yeah.
You just gotta do Kole as far as possible.
I can't believe you got that.
My safe pocket.
This is fucking crazy.
Thank you better.
But how do I keep it?
What is unload backpack?
You unload your backpack.
How do I put, if I put it, do I just move the, move it over
the stash yep how do i move it how do i move it uh well well
hit continue you just go to continue continue do i not click
unload backpack it's okay yeah just my screen's black why do
i oh unload it okay i mean if you want to unload it you can
it's up to you depending how you want to prioritize but it's
not going to do anything oh okay unload yep unload okay yay
i don't Are you having regrets playing with this yet?
I got in my sash now!
There you go.
Uh, no, no regrets, no regrets.
I had round feedback.
How much did you enjoy the last round?
I loved it.
Of course you did.
There you go.
Me too.
Yay!
We're going to buried city this time.
Wait, what do I have to... Oh, wait.
Customize my raider?
Oh, I got skill tree.
okay you can climb and vote more easily oops your movement
speed while crouching is increased who the fuck wants to
have faster movement speed when you're crouched oh sorry
hold on are you okay red tree but i'm yellow yellow should
be yellow
oh is survival more damage oh survival is the best okay
apparently survival is the best guys you know that haha
sorry survival is the best what is the fittest i'm gonna do
that oh red is cute doki cute turn your mic up just like
just by a uh a tiny bit a pinch a pinch yeah wait did you
not max you tried maxing i have you at 200 i have you at 200
yeah yeah yeah i'm at 119 yeah are you i think there's
something wrong with your setup bro something Maybe I turn
up...
Well, Altair's really loud, so maybe I turn him down and
then I turn the...
Hello, my name's Altair.
I'm turning you down as we speak.
Why would you... No, Battle, you're turning me down!
I'm losing my power!
Yay!
I think I got it.
Security breach?
I...
I put it in red so I can loot better.
Okay.
Where's my stash?
Oh, there it is.
Oh, there's my yellow, guys.
See that?
Right here?
Yeah, we all see it.
Yeah, do I see it?
Yeah, okay.
It's fucking great.
Thanks.
Yeah.
How do I even use the yellow?
Oh, I need a specific gun for it.
Oh, the rattler.
I have a rattler.
Yeah, that gun sucks.
Oh.
That's what I mean, it's great.
It's great.
You guys should use it.
Oh, keep it.
i have a i have a stitcher oh i have a radler three i'm
bringing that in i got wait is the stitcher good uh it's
situational it yeah i think he's right i hate that that was
correct but yes it's a situational oh use a free loadout i
guess okay yeah you could use a free loadout i mean listen
there's nothing wrong with using a free loadout can you wait
how do i use the free loadout do i just ready up uh okay so
when you go to hit play you see free loadout at the top
there yeah oh and i just oh thanks yeah you got it you got
it i'm here to help wait you should bring your loadout i
gotta bring some i'm gonna bring a shitty loadout i'll bring
my legend i'll bring my legendary load out why because
that's how much i trust in us it's an even trade we just
died horribly no no no we got two remember it's just the arc
third party does if you have better guns we probably could
look see i'll bring my legendary right now look it's in my
it's in my it's in my not safe pocket too uh-huh i'm not
even gonna put in my safe pocket that's how much that's how
much i in us okay well I'm bringing a shitty load out but
it's not free hey see he's slowly believing us okay he's
believing in us listen I'm not disappointing you guys I am
actually quite proud the only thing is that this game is
very stressful and I get I'm under a lot of stress and I am
not exactly a natural born leader because I had a diet coke
at 4 p.m.
it's a it's a rough day bro you were such a good leader in
battlefield what happened I was confident Why are you
confident here?
It's the same game!
No, it's not!
You're going to get us to Battle Royale number one.
I have a gun.
It's practically the same game.
You of all people should know that's not true.
Third person, first person.
It's only two degrees of experience.
You know, like Battlefield is first person.
Arc Raider is third person.
Like it's like, it's practically the same thing.
It's like how Overwatch is first person.
Marvel Rivals is third person.
wait marvel arrival is this third person yeah what the fuck
yeah are you fucking kidding me that's why they sell so much
skins because because then you can goon to the ass i've
never noticed that that's why yeah i would get it bro they
had a one billion dollar land like how else are they funding
all that bro the world's a terrible place how do you think
they're funding all that fucking lands and like sponsors and
shit.
Bro, you know they had another VTuber tournament today for
Rifles after the one yesterday?
I was like, yeah, I was like, what?
Who did that?
Yeah, they sponsored another one on the next day.
It's like Fortnite doing that $100 million in their
competitive number when that was announced back in the day.
Yeah, yeah, now every lands do a million dollar tournament.
We're rocking.
There's like here library okay it's a new life and all tears
brought us to the worst map in the game so just it's time we
worse what do you mean i hate this map this place is
horrible we're together savages wait but we are marauders
we're not in part of any like we're not part of any party no
i'm yet to see anyone talk to us people don't talk in trios
that much what about be like no no you gotta be the change
we want to see if you kill people that are innocent they
start What the heck?
What you- Hello!
Wait, why is my- my thing not working?
Give me a sec.
I want to talk to strangers.
Hello!
It's me, Gavin Spittle!
Can you guys hear me?
Yeah!
No.
Oh, I turned my off.
Yes, sir.
All right, there we go.
Okay.
Hello!
I can hear you.
Hello, everyone!
We're part of your party!
You're- Have you guys heard of VTubers?
Okay, no, they're definitely- Don't say that.
Don't say that.
We're VTubers.
No, no, no, no.
We are not.
We love, um, Mr. We're, we love that arc raider streamer.
Your favorite arc raider streamer is my favorite.
Hey, what's up guys?
It's Rita's Altair underscore Hall of Star Shooter.
Okay.
I don't know this man.
I don't know this guy.
I love watching.
I love watching, um, Fazeklan.
They're my favorite streamer girl.
Yeah, Fazek bro.
Yeah.
Fazek bro.
Look out look out Okay There's people Hey what part of the
army are you guys part of?
Which army are you guys part of?
Yeah which group Watch out dude he's in there they're in
there They're in here I shot him in the ass Wait Oh they're
up there Guys what group are you guys part of Good shot Oh
hey Wait he's trying to talk back he's talking back Hello,
can you guys hear us?
No, we're not playing with the- No, we just want to be nice!
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait!
Sorry, our third- Sorry, our third's a random and he's he
doesn't know what he's doing.
Hey, have you guys heard of VTubers before?
Oh my god, I'm fucking okay, okay, I-
Dude, these like, you guys are in the wrong one!
You guys left!
We're not that bad.
Um, what are they doing?
Are they having a war right now?
You guys should have answered our question.
We're coming in.
I got, I don't know.
I don't think I got him.
I didn't get him.
Did he drop?
He dropped, he dropped, he dropped.
He went downstairs.
I'm not gonna follow that.
You got a heal, bro.
I feel like I was gonna follow him if you went in.
Be careful.
I'm covering you.
I don't have really good like assault rifles or anything.
I just have a...
Radler?
I just have a Pharaoh.
Wait, how do you turn down the flashlight?
There you go.
And a hand pin.
Why are we so mean to people?
I think he's down there.
I think he definitely is.
Whoa.
Wouldn't he have a team?
Yeah.
Where is his team?
Maybe they all died.
I don't know.
team was up top was weren't they never assume that the team
is dead first mistake of war yeah i was gonna say we saw one
guy and that's it what happened where are his team he must
have ran he must have ran suspicious i heard don't shoot oh
maybe he extracted you're going to the extraction point i'm
gonna check it no i don't know where the extraction all
right so people camp this is that is this the extraction
point the further we go down yeah the fact that the arc
aren't dead is a good indication that the extraction point
has not been used they do respond but oh i mean we should
just leave it didn't we yeah yeah i think we go back up yeah
this is a colossal waste of our time unless yeah i was
thinking this was a waste of our time yeah it's a good good
good not a waste of our time we're for together right shut
up um all right so we lost that guy but there were people
above us there you look they're talking still you hear them
talking i don't hear them talking i saw i saw the uh
notification that that they're that there was talking oh
that's me geez what an entrance i think they're still not
building all the way up whoa i'm so oh wait there's gunshots
over there going up
Wee!
What is Altair doing?
Washing windows?
What is going on?
He's watching.
Watch.
Oh!
There's a sniper.
There is a sniper.
There is a sniper that just sniped me.
Oh, whoa.
He's here.
I was just watching the window washer.
Oh, that's a defib.
Where the...
Okay, it's still the charger.
I have a defib.
I see him.
Oh my god, I was not expecting that.
Wacked him Oh my god I don't even know where you guys are
Where you guys are seeing this guy He's that far He's got
advantage I can't see him Yeah He's talking to the right On
me on the right corner Oh my god Okay okay Okay okay On my
way Oh I don't know how fast I can go I got him He's down
Nice Are you peaceful Hello Don't ask somebody that Ha ha ha
Are you a nice guy?
He said yeah!
Stay there!
Do you know VTubers?
Okay, don't say that.
I'm gonna ask every time.
If you don't, you better know now!
I don't know this guy.
I'm about to get killed by one!
Oh my god!
Okay, did you kill the other guy?
Did you kill the...
There's one guy?
Yeah, he's dead.
I need to loot him, but he's crawled away.
He's dead.
He's like, he's gone gone.
Ow, fucking hell.
Bro, okay.
I'm like, okay, I'm fucked up right now.
Oh, those guys are still at it.
Yeah.
God, maybe we do extract shit.
Yeah, might as well.
I mean, I don't have any actual loot, to be fair.
No, we got kind of a rough...
Rough run here.
Oh, this guy kill me.
Don't worry, I got you.
Can you cover?
I'll res him.
covered oh my yeah i don't have shields i can i want to loot
that guy but those dudes up there gotta shoot me to get his
smoke grenade i have a shield recharger if you want it i
have rechargers but my shield is broken like my actual shoot
let me oh it's actually broken broken yeah it's broken
broken where's the body where's the body it's uh right there
oh god these are guys are fucking blast we had his it's
there all right here we go oh i believe i believe it lasts a
real short guys no the smoke is literally still there i
literally still yeah i still see the smoke in front of me
you're so fine like i see it so for me yeah yeah i'm like i
still see yeah that was good that was good smoke yeah also
his shield was also broken right damn right it's a good
smoke i know how to smoke wait look at all are you sure
about that i i've learned i gotta die out here you're okay
you didn't have a shield all right we're gonna get out of
here so fine i used my last grenade by the way but let's
just leave i mean like doesn't really matter if we die we
don't we didn't even loot anything well do you want to lose
the stuff that you have i i didn't bring anything i used a
free loader well yeah but the stuff that you have you can
bring back i didn't even bring anything so you would you
rather just die meaningless yeah in a in a effort okay free
is free wait you have your own do you care about your load
up no i don't give a fuck yeah i think it's better than i
think what the oh okay okay oh we don't win this fight no no
no no no pick me up pick me up right now it's down again
what is happening I think we can...
Oh, okay.
They have the rocketeer on them.
We can get the fuck out of here while they're distracted by
that thing.
Let's go.
I just got snaked again.
Oh, hey.
Wait, now I have stuff.
Guys, I have stuff now.
Just take all that shit.
Oh, shit.
You should be fine.
Garbage.
Oh, shit.
Just found something.
Look, and now we can extract.
Let's go.
Oh, someone else is extracting too.
Oh, on me, on me!
Are you friendly?
Are you a good nice person?
This guy ain't friendly.
This is what we do to friendly people around here.
VTubers!
Lights out!
Alright, now loot is dead body!
And we get the fuck out of here!
Yeah!
Oh, he had a pistol!
Good, good.
Then you have stuff we can leave.
Well, he has so much stuff.
I can't even loot everything.
Ah!
Watch out, watch out, watch out.
He has a rubber donkey!
He has a rubber donkey, guys!
Does someone get it?
grab the rubber duckie, I saw that on Twitter.
I take everything.
Give nothing back.
All right, let's go.
I shall.
And stop shooting people and asking them if they're
friendly.
No, it's friendly.
Okay, they die.
Everyone dies.
Michael Gorbius, are you friendly?
I think it's funny that, you know, I shoot them and then I
kill them and I'm like, are you friendly?
You know, just to rub it in.
And then you kill them too.
You know?
And it'll be like, it gives them hope that maybe I'll spare
them.
People are extracting down here.
Okay.
They're extracting.
Oh, fuck.
Turn your flashlight off.
It's my flashlight.
I die in one shot.
What we're going to want to do is wait for the tray to get
here and run onto it.
We don't win this fight, I don't think.
Okay, I cover.
I want to say we don't win this fight.
I'm looking behind us, so you guys better copy covering.
I'm going to take the adrenaline shot.
I have full of adrenaline now.
Yeah, right here, right here.
You see him?
He's real low real low.
He's dead.
Nice.
Are you friendly?
He's jumping more more more this more.
He's broken I'm on fire.
I Can't fucking see I'm down.
I'm down.
Oh my god.
Oh no, they're not friendly guys Guys The extraction Guys, I
don't think we're getting distracted right now.
Okay, wait, wait, wait use you as you see you're the body
block okay yep yep yep i'll tear yes there's something wrong
there my friend hey we're friendly hello i don't think
they're friendly anymore elter i saw a guy and i had to
shoot him he was just sitting there i thought if i had shot
him you die well we did kill him but you have to account for
the two other potential people that might be alive in the
team that why did you guys shoot them why it wasn't you guys
it was regis all better did you hear me when i res you did
they hear it
that was three people that was three fucking people you know
this was your fault elter if you didn't shoot them i would
have got my they could have just yeah they could have called
the training i'm sorry I'm sorry.
I could have got my rubber ducky.
It was my rubber ducky.
It wasn't my inventory.
I was like, no, I was like, get the rubber ducky.
Get it.
For yourself.
But you guys.
Yeah.
I got a kill, guys.
We got a kill.
So if there's extracts aren't taken, then...
Oh, I got it.
people use it again yeah i got oh i thought it was under the
tarco where it just gets taken it gets taken my bad yeah
forget what you know about tarcov for one oh i like tarcov i
i never played tarcov oh free loadout i unlocked spaceport
let's go i got a chicken what does the chicken do he
collects resources for you oh i can train him we have a dog
call oh Yeah, dog collar.
Yeah, yeah, this is just a dog.
Works surprisingly well in Beddle too.
Silence!
Thanks for playing with us, Beddle.
Yay!
Isn't it a great time?
I'm having a fun time.
Yeah.
Welcome to Team Sacrifice.
whack whack yeah am i an honorary fucking member is that
what i am yeah we're gonna be whacking if you wanted to we
just gotta initiate we're like rgb without the g i like
being the blown out uncle that isn't a part of this usually
you're like the uncle that visits the the racist uncle that
visits that's a thing whoa do i have to add that first part
oh i always need to You know and then just starts seeing
some shit.
I'm drunk and I'm racist.
Yeah, the drunk uncle.
The drunk racist uncle at Thanksgiving.
You're him.
Oh, good.
Yeah.
So I'm a- I mean, you already look like one in our graders.
Like you already look like the part.
Well, my hair was fucking brown when we started this fucking
stream.
Wait, RGB is actually perfect because we have Regis, Gavis
and Bird.
bird yeah my family is there's a lot of birds out there oh
spaceport oh yes it's my sister's pheasant bird yeah Doki
the bird father turkey bird guys why can't are you I'm a
bird I'm Doki bird you're just a bird you know you're not
specific bird i'm doing she's tomato bird right no that's
the the thing inside the bird oh my every bird it's like how
every pigeon is a government spy oh that's what i was
desperate i was desperately trying to figure out what kind
of bird you were when i was making my thumbnail and i just
landed on i landed on chicken so that's yeah i mean it's i'm
I'm I'm my color is like a chicken like a chicken.
I feel like a lot of birds taste like chicken That's usually
what people say like what's the taste like taste like
chicken Where are the fucking loot here?
I've always wanted to go visit Axel in Australia and then
you know eat some ostrich there What about like kangaroos?
I heard the meat for kangaroos is like really tough because
it's all muscle Oh, we can try Because like we can have a
mukbang You've seen like the, like the, oh, that hurt.
Have you seen like the buff-ass kangaroo pictures?
Yeah.
They're fucking jacked.
Yeah, they look like they're on steroids.
I wonder what happens if you gave kangaroo steroids.
Like, can they get buffered?
Is that like animal abuse?
Super kangaroo?
Yeah, I think so.
I was like, like, is that like, is that like, what are they
called when, like, when, like, the thing to be able to use
animals to test stuff?
What is that called?
uh animal testing yeah yeah yeah i think that would be for
science you know you i don't know how jacked up can a
kangaroo get like what's the negative consequences of using
steroids other than a smaller domination you guys know that
it shrinks the peepee if you use steroids yeah oh so that's
why mine's so large so i'm just thinking like is it really
animal abuse if are pps or smaller like do you think the
female kangaroos care yeah but do you think like female
kangaroos would care okay what do female kangaroos care
about do they care about that or do they care about what the
size of the pouch is yeah it's not about the size it's the
it's the motion of the ocean you know ocean of the ocean is
crazy This is up to a kangaroos.
I don't know.
I'm just wondering if kangaroos...
I think Doki is a furry.
No, oh, wait.
But you guys heard of the furry of the year?
The debate of furry of the year?
So you?
What is that debate?
So every year, every year they nominate what...
I actually had a YouTube short posted about this today.
Every year, they pick one honorary character to represent
the furry of the year.
And it's been like...
wolves have been winning for 10 years now like wolf
characters so you know how okay so last year was oh my god i
forgot what the extracting over there oh okay oh there's a
big ship over there yeah you don't want to mess with that
guy there's a dead there's a guy who's down though why is it
i'm just trying to make sure the bat wins guys i'm trying to
make sure moist
Sonar Critical will win 3 of the year.
I'm tired of the cycle.
Guys, they hurt.
They hurt.
Ah, what?
What hitting me?
Guys, we're ready to get inside.
I need a heal.
I didn't know what the fuck he shot me just now.
I'm down.
Oh, my greed.
Oh, my what is going on okay um i'm gonna i'm gonna try and
pick him up oh my you are not safe you are not safe i just
i'm so safe i'm so safe we can't fight that so just try and
get inside if i die i die what the is if i die i die
anyway so so every year there is a better we're safe we're
so safe i'm not that thing's so fucking out there thank you
miss bird i appreciate i didn't pick up anything it's okay
wait can we pull the extract while we're down oh fuck i'm
gonna try yes you can pull the extract get the fuck out out
of here why the fuck did you not do that you have been down
here i am fucking crawling like oh my god yeah we extract I
didn't know that.
Why couldn't you come over here?
Oh, because there are two people.
Tell them you're friendly.
If you tell them you're friendly.
No one's friendly in the scout forsaken world.
You understand?
You're just, you're so pessimistic, Beto.
We're so jaded.
What happened to this?
Yeah, Beto, we're friendly.
We're nice.
Yeah, we're, it's because like Altair now, we haven't gone
through the the turmoil of war yet in this game, so.
We haven't had to see the light leave another's eyes.
and we still have like lights in our eyes and not dead
inside yet man more is so fun we haven't seen our conrad's
die yet we're still
no i need to extract now battle you could create the most
tragic backstory for you now it's a really hard enough for
this lifestyle if you die here if you die here that maybe
maybe we'll become just like you Is there this guy yet?
Oh, shit.
A little bit.
Oh, wait.
I didn't even realize there was a dead guy in front of me.
Wait, wait.
Did you extract it?
No, I'm trying to get the fuck out of here.
Better why aren't you extracting?
Shut up!
It's trying to move the fuck out!
I'm thinking it's right above me!
You're fine.
Oh!
Uh-oh.
Oh, they don't have object permanent.
No!
Whoa!
Wait, you can roll?
Yeah, left off.
Left off.
Oh, my God.
You guys...
Okay.
That was not in my tutorial.
It was.
No, it wasn't.
Maybe you should have asked.
Dude, you didn't tell me.
A coach would tell their student without having to ask.
Listen, there's a lot of things that I don't understand in
one of those games that I just have to teach me.
Yeah, and why aren't you teaching me it one by one?
Oh, my God.
Run, run.
I hope it shoots you.
I'm your coach.
You're not doing a very good job at coaching.
Yay!
You can, oh my god, wait, how do you swap shoulders?
Oh my gosh, did you not go through tutorial?
You can hit X.
Oh hey, I got items.
Unload backpack.
Oh!
It was one item.
Hit X to swap shoulder, left alt to...
Oh, okay.
Yay, thanks coach.
I can craft stuff now.
I found a good weapon.
A looting MK, light shield.
Okay, uh, not enough resources.
Oh, I couldn't craft a hairpin.
I want to craft a hairpin.
Is hairpin good?
No, it's terrible.
Oh.
Why?
I feel like you could lock-pick stuff with it, right?
I'll craft this.
Nice altar.
You win the largest comedy joke of the night award.
It wasn't a comedy joke.
I was actually serious about that.
You can actually lock-pick, right?
Can you?
So what is a good...
What is a...
good uh how do i how do i use my backpack oh there i did it
so what is a good gun then well well for starter weapons the
pharaoh is a very good gun but it's better when it's paired
with another weapon a pharaoh is a long-range weapon with
one shot in it and it can and it can it can break shields
pretty quickly if they have light shields it breaks them in
one hit okay but normal what you want to do is shoot them
with the pharaoh then switch to your sidearm and shoot them
with that because you know switch to your sidearm is faster
than reloading plus you can add pressure uh when it comes to
when it comes to that situation after cracking their shields
because they're gonna need to heal can you explain this in
marvel rival's terms oh um okay so the pharaoh can break
shields oh fuck i don't no you're doing great that all don't
worry so okay you said a very long paragraph and then you
said one sentence well this is tough when you make me
explain it in a game that's not even remotely similar can
you explain it in league of legends terms then wait i don't
play league though can you explain it in uh club penguin
terms club penguin yeah i got banned from club penguin for
trying would they do that i bro played as a waiter at club
penguin yeah i went and i was like i might get the on the
ground and then i got there
wonder why hmm i wonder why hey i'm ready i got a gun oh is
there any other questions you have that maybe i could
explain well you didn't really explain it very well i did
explain it in But I'm just a baby.
Beto, why are you red?
You don't have red in your design.
Why are you red?
Yeah, he does.
I see the red right now in his goose avatar.
A puppet.
Yeah, that's a goose.
No, I'm talking about your fucking discord icon, you fucking
idiot.
Oh,
I didn't bring any ammo, guys.
That's pink.
That's magenta.
Oh, my gosh.
Give me a sec.
I need to make sure I have ammo.
What is the ammo type of this?
Heavy ammo.
Where's heavy ammo?
That all?
Oh, guys.
I don't have heavy ammo.
Can I like mooch off of your heavy ammo, guys?
Let me see if I have any.
Yeah, let me...
I can craft some for you.
Yeah, I don't have enough to craft heavy ammo.
Okay.
it's fine not yes you guys i don't have enough to craft
heavy ammo better i don't have any sounds like you do can
you craft me some money showing my chat right now that it's
zero why are you saying see guys like that as if like
there's something to be said no because people in my chat
didn't believe me i'm like look see i made you 40 bullets is
that gonna be enough i don't know i think so i mean it's one
shot right you have to shoot 40 times yeah i can do that
okay You're welcome.
Thank you, battle.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
Elder, do you want to ask him for any ammo that you need?
Uh, I think I'm good, actually.
Are you sure?
I mean, he has all the loot for it.
I'm 100% sure.
Okay.
Thousand percent sure.
Okay, guys.
Okay, ready?
We're gonna go again.
Yay!
Oh, sorry.
I need to get ammo.
Oh, my God.
Okay.
Brother, you're doing a great job.
Thanks.
I'm very stressed.
I'm here to appreciate you.
Let's do them, you know?
Doing my best, guys.
Everybody that joined us just becomes mind-broken.
We just destroy them.
I don't know why.
I think we're, like, great people.
Yeah.
We've just been fighting them with their positivity.
I know!
We're so positive.
Positivity.
But are you having fun?
Yes.
I'm having fun.
you guys as my friends you see me as a friend you are a
friend yes i would not be here right now yay would you be
friends in the future if this keeps up yeah okay guys let's
see you this is a new raid okay let's try and look alive and
not get distracted by shiny it's the question you need your
ammo yeah yeah yeah there you go thank you okay you're
welcome oh my gosh one bullet one bullet one knife one shot
headshot but battle did you did you get my emma
okay i know how to i know how to shoot people now okay try
out that try out switching shoulders it's very important oh
i switched the switching shoulders over to my mouse button
oh my god i don't like that You can change your crosshair
Okay, wait, okay.
I actually like that.
Okay.
You like that?
Okay, okay Wait, if I'm right-handed should I be looking at
should my person be on the left or the right?
Well, I just switched depending on the wall.
Oh, it's the wall peeking.
So like you're against this wall Then you're gonna want to
go to the left side.
Oh, I see.
Oh My god, you guys are so smart.
It's like you play like extraction shooters or something
Yeah, but I could have won a Marvel rival rival tournament
you know that could be cool too yeah i know that's on you
what i'm just regis alter here huh what do you mean betto
you fucking won the one with me i was trying to be an oh
yeah yeah i know right me and betto were both chat winners
here the two times i'm the two times hey i got second place
in a mario cart tournament one time and they didn't pay me
out but yeah that's on you Yeah, that's on you.
They didn't pay you out.
Yeah, it's on you.
Yeah.
Battle, can you pay me out, please?
No.
Don't be a...
Don't be a leech out there.
Earn your...
I'm not being a leech.
I'm being a...
Yeah, earn your... That's on you, bro.
You gotta talk to the Mario Kart, people.
It's okay.
Yeah, I'm part of...
Wait, what?
Someone just shot.
Where are they?
Are you friendly?
It sounded close.
Oh, fuck.
Altair?
This is not a time to be joking.
There's actually people around here.
What do you mean?
Okay, don't worry.
I'm geared up and I'm ready.
You think?
What if I talk to them?
I'm a girl.
They might not shoot us because I'm a woman.
We should go over there.
Oh, contrary, Doki Bird, they may shoot you more.
You don't know that then you don't know that We could try
yeah, let's try let's try the woman's trap.
Do you want to try the woman's trap?
Yeah, I want to try the woman's trap.
I'll be like wait, I got the voice.
I got the voice.
I got the voice for it.
Don't worry guys Don't worry though who are we in relation
to you though?
Are we just hiding just hide just hide?
I'll be like I'm by myself.
My team died.
Oh my god, we can do the strat where I jump them Yeah, yeah.
We take very much.
Yeah, I'll be like, guys, I'll be like, are you friendly?
My team died.
This is some Mad Max shit.
We just like...
This is what we need to do to survive out here.
I don't know.
I just started playing.
I don't know where the extraction is.
This is the first strategy that I've liked so far.
You're a heartless man.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah, he's the one that's the issue, not me.
The who came up with the plan.
How could you battle?
Yeah, how could you battle?
You're the heartless one here, not me.
Yeah, apparently.
I'm just a woman, you know?
That was never going to want to play games with me ever
again.
Well, someone's like, would work if it wasn't Doki Bird.
These normies don't know who I am, guys.
We'll be fine.
My name sounds so, so nice and say so.
And then Michael Gorbius comes out of the bush and says,
hey, I'm also a woman.
Hello there.
Excuse me.
Can I use my credit card?
I'd like to use my credit card.
Do you have anything gluten-free?
Oh, hello, there is a- Full inventory, I'm ready to go.
I am.
I'm going to try and loot this.
Oh, I'm looting a desk.
You guys are like raccoons.
What do you mean by that?
What do you mean by raccoons, huh?
I could.
Taking all that garbage.
You don't know that.
I have, like, a purple.
You know what?
The best way of getting stuff is killing the enemy and
taking all their shit.
It's instant gratification.
That's not how I got the legendary.
Ooh.
Oh.
Wait, I have something.
Maybe you excluded more.
You might have got your own legendary.
Oh,
that's so cool.
That's so cool.
Keep playing.
Wait, wait.
Wait, I got it.
You're missing a jam session over here, buddy.
Yeah, bro.
Look at this.
all right people look alive you're under attack what do you
do oh it's an arc it's an army it's an attack i look at
quick donkey bird go out there oh i like how it there's just
the art creators i don't get over here there's the arc i
like how the arc shot the men and not me see i told you
woman's shot works did i know you're a woman that you have
your helmet on yeah they do that's not the arc shooting us
that's not no those are players we're being shot by players
hello are you guys real people they're really far away they
are not going to be interviewed you mean that he saw his
dancing and he shot us that's so up man i would have joined
in
Oh, good hell.
Wait, wait, wait.
Oh, I can't...
There's something behind us.
Oh, that's the arc.
Isn't that the arc?
This is the arc.
Hello.
Nice.
We're inside now.
How do I... How come sometimes I can't dance?
Oh, there you go.
Check this out.
Check this out, buddy.
Oh, Jesus!
What happened?
Did you try to show those rollers?
Put the fucking foot away.
Wait, how come you got damaged?
Wait, actually, what happened?
There was a turret.
Oh, oops.
It hurt a lot.
I'm fine.
I can hear the flu from like where I'm at the third floor.
Don't tell him!
Don't tell him.
Oh shit, I'm fine.
I was enjoying my flout.
Your flout?
I'm a floutist.
Blue.
Hi battle.
I swear better.
The women's chat's gonna work.
You just wait and see.
Okay.
Just wait and see.
That's this.
There's people in this vicinity shooting right at us.
Oh yeah.
They're up in here.
I'm going in here.
Oh, what the fuck I missed.
I missed.
Nice suit.
Extended shotgun mag.
Nah.
Evil Roomba.
Yeah, I knocked down the evil Roomba guys.
Does he go down?
No, he doesn't.
But I'm scared.
Guys, I don't know.
Oh, I know how to get down from here.
so far from me what are you guys doing huh you didn't wait
up wait up yeah are we not a team war waits for no one whoa
there's a big drone above me and i'm a little scared oh hey
there's a cop oh and that's not there's an a10 word hog out
there guys yeah there is something outside
what we're getting shot getting shot getting shot still it's
those guys up the thing here we don't bother with them are
they like bad people generally if they're shooting you I'm
gonna lean towards yes okay wait where are they I'm looking
I don't even see them are you sure they're far way up in the
tower oh they're in the tower i was i wanted to see if like
they're friendly or not do you want to go do you want to go
up to them i mean go find out i mean what am i what am i
gonna lose the 40 bullets that betel crafted for me he
painstakingly crafted this for you yeah exactly you can't
lose that exactly well i might i might have to want to test
my theory, my game theory.
Hello, anybody in here?
Oh, it's dark.
Wait, there's a basement in here.
Hello?
Nice.
I shot it and it died.
We good?
Ah!
Spider!
Wait, there's a spider?
The spider blew up.
I don't go through here.
What the fuck is the loot here?
There's no loot in the subway.
We're not really in a zone that has like loot pools.
I mean, there'll be stuff scattered around.
What's the point of being here?
We got to get into the big building.
Maybe there's an entrance.
To get around places.
Oh shit.
There's like nothing here.
Nice!
Watch out, fire!
Oh!
Somebody pushed me into the fire.
There's no collision.
No, no, no, no.
Somebody pushed me.
I saw it.
We actually don't have shields.
Can that be me?
You don't have shields here.
Thank you.
Where do I?
Okay.
Oh, how are you so good?
We're living.
I would jolt mine.
If I should save something, what should I say?
Alter, I swear to God!
Cheers.
We can go launch pad.
How do you guys get up there?
That seems like fun.
Oh, there.
Are there other instruments in this game, Bella?
I sure hope not.
Chat chat.
Are there other instruments in this game?
Wait, wait, wait.
Altair, point.
Good drums.
Okay, put the fluid in your safe pocket Huh put in the safe
pocket so you can you'll never lose it I I can just buy
another one.
No, no, no.
It's so important though What if you lose it?
So you think I'm gonna die, huh?
There's some interesting prioritizing going on The fluid is
so important
Ow ow ow ow ow oh my god these cars are getting shot I'm
getting shot above that Above?
Yeah, by the arcs.
Oh, fuck.
No, no, no.
Players, players.
Wait, where are they?
Above us.
Right here?
Oh.
Are you friendly?
What?
I can't hear you guys.
Huh?
Are you guys friendly?
Hello?
This is my first time playing the game.
Is this a turkey?
what they say i don't know i couldn't hear them it's so
quiet oh we gotta go the guy's coming we don't want to fight
that i have no ammo i can't hear them i want to be able to
hear this guy is it proximity voice chat volume that i boost
their volume or is it boosting my volume i think not sure do
you guys want to start a band but they're in here okay i'll
continue then hello
I'm out of ammo.
Like entirely?
Yeah, you should have made more...
Someone's extracting to our left.
Right here.
Someone's extracting.
I just want to have friends.
I just want to make friends.
Oh, Tara, I'm going to give you a gun.
Oh, really?
Good luck.
Oh, thank you, dude.
Let's go ask these guys extracting if they're friendly,
shall we?
Yeah, yeah.
I can do that.
I'll go in first.
I'll go in first, guys.
I have nothing to lose.
Uh-oh.
So if you know they're not friendly, if you know they're not
friendly, then it's like, I die, you know?
They're here.
Okay, okay, let me in first.
Let me in first.
They're shooting at us.
Are you guys friendly?
I killed one.
Oh.
I'm not.
Welcome to hell.
Sorry, I don't know this other guy on my party.
Have you guys heard of YouTubers?
They left this dude.
Oh, they did?
Wait, wait.
Don't kill him yet.
I want to talk to him.
He killed himself.
Oh.
Well, we can loot him at least.
He was a free loadout.
He had nothing.
Oh.
Well, we can go back to those other guys.
This guy's you.
Oh.
wait this guy's you look at him this is not the map to do
the girl strat we will do this next round it's not girl it's
a woman strat sorry Jesus must have missed that part in the
fucking arc raiders strategy guide you don't know I've read
the art of war
yeah Sun Tzu was like yeah just say hey I'm a girl no no no
no no I'm Sun Tzu did it no no no not I'm a girl's like hey
are you guys friendly friendly friendly and then when they
say that they are friendly you shoot them in the back no and
I'm like I'm like can you guys like help me I don't know how
to do the extraction thing kind of scared I just started
playing today We evil We're gonna become horrible people I
think we already are We didn't do anything We didn't do it
We will Also I killed that man for no good reason Other than
the fact that I wanted to kill somebody Because I was bored
What do you mean you're bored?
That's okay You were bored with us here?
Yeah No I never be bored with you guys Yeah, so why didn't
you kill him?
I just have horrible bloodlust.
You just need to understand.
Okay.
Stop bumping into the cars, guys.
Hello?
Okay.
Nobody's here.
No one's here.
Do you guys want to loot this building?
Do you want to go inside?
Watch out, watch out, watch out.
Hornet, what's a hornet?
Get the thing on this.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Ow!
I'm getting lasered.
Okay, that's it.
I'm using the other gun.
I have another...
I'm running out of ammo.
I have a tire shield.
Oh!
We're fine, right?
These things do so much damage.
They do a lot of damage, and they're tanky as fuck.
They're annoying as hell.
I hate it.
That's really annoying.
I think this is an annoying part of Arc Raiders, the Arc
part.
Yes, yes.
The Arc part is not us.
It's my least favorite part.
Yeah.
The Arc part of the Arc Raiders is pretty annoying.
Yeah, I agree.
Medium ammo.
Over here.
That's what you need for the gun that you had, isn't it?
No, I used Light Noamma.
Oh.
Oh, can you give me my gunback then?
Okay.
Here we go.
I don't need the ammo.
Oh, there's another guy up there.
Yeah, shoot their thrusters.
Is that how you get rid of them faster?
Yeah, apparently.
I said that already.
Oh, my bad.
No.
You guys are too busy fucking giggling at the summer party.
I remembered.
I didn't say I didn't know.
Okay, okay, okay.
That was my fault.
I shouldn't have walked you in.
Hey, why don't you group me up with Altair?
Why did you group me up with this guy?
I'm noticing a constant.
It's been Altair.
Betel, why are you grouping me up with Altair?
Oh, damn it good.
You never expect that one.
Look, yeah, Altair's a visual learner.
You need to be like extra slow with him.
Yeah, Betel, can you show me your credit card?
Wait, where's the extraction?
I don't own a credit card.
Yeah, you don't want to extract?
Don't trust the banks.
I'm just going, Nate.
Okay, let's extract guys.
Let's extract.
Okay.
Never trust the banks.
Thanks guys.
Invest in gold and hide it under your bed.
Invest in mattress.
Oh yeah, it's true.
The mattress value will never drop.
That's right.
Betel, what's the best thing that you have in your
inventory?
Right now?
Yeah.
What color is it?
Blue?
Can I have it?
No.
Wait, is it just green, blue, gold?
Green, blue, pink, gold.
You don't even have a pink?
I don't bring those out too often Unless we're doing like a
super raid and we're not doing that When I'm teaching two
people to play the video game Wait, wait, wait So you do
have a pink then I have plenty of those Oh, you know what
you don't have Don't say it Too fun to have you, thanks I
don't want to hear it It's the same color as me Right Silver
looking at it yeah let's see oh wait would would this stay
open until we like click on it or is it timed uh you know
what I don't know but it stays open for a bit oh we should
just wait why is there a dead body here that's the guy I
shot oh this guy oh my god I forgot about this guy
guys a successful extraction we did it
yeah whoo now let's join the war we're training we're still
good at this game i'm so proud of us yeah i mean that was
good succeeded and i got my and i got my stuff i'm not
finding a lot of treasure though just a lot of crafting
material yeah well we you can use the crafting material to
craft treasures Oh.
That's right.
Oh, I can skill tree now.
Okay, I want to be able to climb a little faster.
Oh, I want to run faster too.
But, um...
Locked doors have the best treasure.
Can I train him yet?
Track resources?
Let's see.
Ooh.
Oh, I don't have to bring anything because I already slide
further Okay, the ammo Okay, the kettle was dog shit.
I feel like Uh, the kettle's not terrible I have a kettle
rattler and uh stitcher which one should I bring Probably a
kettle Oh, I just bring the kettle goes longer ranged and
then uh radler is like a close you you won't be in kissing
range you know you want to okay i see uh what else did i get
i got the adrenaline shot where's the fucking meds here uh
quickies oh there it is shield or charger all right also go
to damn battleground where hair we're gonna want to do the
woman's uh the woman's right yes yes the woman's right yes
okay yes okay yes okay i thought i nearly slipped up called
it something like the girl's strat yeah that's you better
not battle that's offensive don't worry it's gonna work guys
wait if we're gonna do the woman's chat i bring a free
loadout oh yeah maybe that's a good idea yeah no i just a
free loadout it's fine i don't know is this a free loadout
do i have it i think i did yeah i did all right oh inventory
management is a nightmare okay let's go you said which one
damn battlegrounds yeah yeah yeah we should better be the
one be the party leader uh if he goes too yeah he knows he
knows his give him the party leader okay i don't know how to
wait how to figure it out just give it to michael gorbius
yeah give it to michael gorbius uh oh i could just restart
and uh yeah kick from party no i don't know how to do it i'm
sorry i don't not do it either i don't know how to do it
either so what i'm going to do is i'm just going to leave
the no yeah let's do it okay let's see here i want to see if
i can there you go close okay you invite doki yeah invite me
invite me okay okay okay
Wait, or...
Oh, are you online?
Yeah, what?
How did you invite me last time?
I don't...
What do you mean?
I don't think I can invite anybody from in-game.
Oh, maybe...
Oh!
That'll add me.
Wait, recent...
Wait, let me see you.
Add me.
Oh, I found you!
You're the rat icon, right?
Oh, that's me.
That's me.
Yeah, yeah, I found you.
You're the fucking rat right here.
I got you.
The green screen rat.
Oh, my God.
There is some really fucked up names in this game.
There is.
Oh, and then there's a guy named Pizza.
Pizza.
Wait, did you...
I sent you a friend request.
Yes.
And then you invite me.
Oh, there you go.
Okay, free load.
I'm ready reload out I'm ready let's do the strategy that I
that I don't really want to say anymore because I feel like
why I'm a woman I'm not don't worry you're an honor you're
an honoring woman I'm giving you the pass the woman Yes!
Yes!
Let's hear it fucking ready up.
I'm sorry!
I have a full inventory!
I can't!
I'm trying to figure out what I can do!
Bro, I was doing mathematics right now.
Bro, you just started playing the game.
What kind of mathematics are you doing?
Yeah!
What do you have?
Yeah, what do you fucking have?
We just started!
Too much!
It's not letting me start!
Okay, whatever.
I guess I'm just not going to go free.
What?
All right, let's go.
All right, I'm ready.
All right, yeah, I'll go.
Oh, that was easy.
I can't wait.
Wait, have you just been doing randomize or something for
maps?
No, I've just been kind of picking whichever.
It's just been feeling it.
out yeah feeling it out well here we go
all right guys we could do the we could do the doki strategy
on top of the other strategy that i'm thinking of here okay
what was the other strategy there's a place i go that i like
to hide in and i go out and jump at people and scare them if
we go there fast oh we got a good spawn for it we could use
doki as bait yeah and hide behind these boxes and jump out
and shoot them.
Yippee, baby.
Let's go quick, quick, quick.
We have a great spawn and we will definitely be the first
ones there.
It might take a minute for people to get there.
But you won't need to bait them by like talking in chat
like, oh, help, you know.
You just, you know.
No, no, I'll just be like, hello.
Are you guys friendly?
Well, you should hide that voice.
I do not have a good gun for this.
My team died and I just started playing.
They're like, my team left me.
They just shoot me on the spot if I did that.
Oh, they might shoot you at the spot, too.
No, no, no.
If they shoot me in the spot, then they're very bad people.
Wait, there's people.
Alarm, alarm.
How do you know?
Oh, is that?
Am I...
Am I headshots on backwards?
Do you know where you're going?
Uh, yeah.
Wait.
What?
Yes.
We're here.
We're going to have to destroy the earth first.
Oh my god, that was scary.
These poor arcs, what do they do?
So?
Yeah.
Oh, it's this spot!
This is where we got the legendary.
Remember this?
Wait, don't open it.
Don't open it.
If it's open, then maybe...
No, just open one.
Yeah, it's correct.
Okay.
Now we hide here.
Yeah.
And Doki, you could be like, here.
Yeah, yeah.
I'll be where here.
It'd be like where that ping is.
If you want to use yourself as bait, after all.
Okay.
But what if they just shoot, what if they shoot me before I
could tell that you're here?
Well, isn't that kind of part of the strategy that you
already intended on happening?
That's true.
No, no.
But like, it would be better if they don't see me and then
I'm like to hear the voice inside, you know?
Okay.
Yeah.
I mean, then you could come hide with us if you want to do
it that way.
We'll do it that way and then I'll come out.
Oh, hello?
Oh, there's people there.
Hello?
Are you guys friendly?
Yes.
Oh, hi Sorry my my team died.
I'm really scared.
Sorry.
I'm a team died.
I'm really scared Oh You're the what?
You're the what?
But what do you mean you're the what?
What I'm what
No, wait I'm low.
I'm low.
There's one left.
There's one left Sorry, what happened wait, wait, wait.
I'm not part of this.
I'm not part of this Sorry, let me put let me put one
mushroom in my ass Huh, and then kill me.
That's all I need for that fucking chicken.
Nice.
What chicken?
He wants to put a mushroom on his butt.
He said chicken Come here.
Let me just grab this mushroom that's over here.
Yeah, he's getting his friends up.
I think It's literally behind this.
What's going on?
I'm shielding.
I told you guys the women's trap works.
I did work.
It worked.
I told you guys.
I told you guys, you said believe me.
Yeah.
I'm going in at all.
Where's it?
Oh, behind me.
I can't focus.
I can't focus at all.
Doki, you're only in hope.
You're only hoping.
I'm thinking, look.
You're going, why?
You're going!
You're going to leave me, guys.
Doki!
Hey!
Hey buddy, can you pick me up please?
Hey, I don't know.
I'm new to this game.
I don't know what I'm doing.
I hope you guys are having a good day today.
Have you guys heard of VTubers?
You know, they were not going to shoot us if you didn't.
Why is that the whole point?
Why is there no, no, no.
I meant like, I meant like, why didn't you Let all of them
come in before you fucking shot them.
This is so fucking stupid.
The whole point.
What is stupid?
No, no, no.
You guys fucked up the strat.
That is not true.
We did exactly.
We did not.
We literally magned up the guy.
You guys didn't do the strat currently.
You gotta wait for all the.
I blame the woman.
I, that was a successful bet.
that bait was so fucking successful it was a success no no
you guys fucked up the whole thing i did my job i did my job
and lured them in and you guys did not finish the job i
can't believe it like let's do the same again next round you
didn't finish the fucking job i did my duties as the woman i
she turned on voice chat for a second
they were like they were like like letting me chill and
everything and like we just walk here i was like oh sorry
sorry you scared me over there like i only saw one battle
shot okay i i we killed them quickly after that though
yeah the plan worked but it executed poorly from the men
here whoa whoa whoa whoa us men did our men job
don't worry guys I'm just you know I can I just leave I
don't have anything anyway yeah how do I leave I surrender
don't have can't grandma loot now
Yeah, premature shooting there.
Yeah, exactly.
That was pitiful.
We got to try again.
Yeah, we got to try this shot.
We'll execute it correctly now.
I am not about to be gaslit.
I'll tell you should be the woman next.
What do you mean?
Hello?
No, it's too obvious.
Hey.
Yeah, do better, guys.
Do better.
Just, I'm going to freak out.
Hey, but it worked.
I told you the woman's shot works.
Wait, there's a voice changer in the game.
Yeah, there is.
Okay.
Where's like a charm?
Also, what the fuck were they saying?
He was like, are you part of the, is that the team names?
I see he's probably talking about the streamer teams, yeah.
Oh, I was like, what?
I was actually, that one was true.
That one wasn't a lie for that reaction.
That was actual confusion.
That's really, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, guys.
I'm giving people trust issues.
Let's go.
Now this is a fun game.
I'm laying, I'm going to this time, layout mines.
Yeah.
Oh, oh.
Oh, so you're bringing your big guns then this time.
Not really.
I'm just bringing one mine to see if anyone steps on it.
Wait, there's no friendly fire on the mines, right?
There is.
I think you could trip on.
You could probably trip on them, so be careful.
Beto, you shouldn't have told me that.
Okay.
You know, me and mines.
I don't know.
We'll have a blast, buddy.
Come on.
Me, you, the stratosphere.
Okay.
No, guys, I won't step on it, guys.
I'll be okay.
I believe in us.
Okay, I'm going to try something out.
The thing is, the mines might bait this plan.
They might see it before they come in.
Before they see it?
What about nades?
Nades are good.
Can we do nades instead?
Are we heading there now?
Do you want to go?
Do you want to do it again?
Yeah, let's do it.
Let's do it.
work maybe i don't it up yeah yeah exactly now oh oh that
was now that i've been sufficiently gaslit into my own
ability okay then that that voice changes shit is so bad
that it's not convincing at all i'm a girl i'm a real boy
wow what the do you not hear out there no oh i haven't
turned off because I'm ready for the impending just
awfulness.
He's using the voice changer right now.
He sounds like a fucking... It does not sound like a girl.
I will say it does not sound like a girl out there.
Oh my god, he's a real girl now.
Honestly, Beto, you're missing out.
They're not saying any gamer words yet.
Yet.
You're missing out, bro.
I've lost one VOD already, alright?
You're missing out.
Fucking fucking.
I'm fine.
He didn't shoot me.
Yeah, I'm fine.
I'm fine.
It didn't shoot me.
Is that turret?
Yeah, there's a sniper turret.
It's like aiming at you only.
Yeah.
That's okay.
You're on a free loadout.
I know I'm not wait you're not oh oh you you want to
distract the work work I want to win you understand should
have should have executed it better then don't you fucking
forget that no way Elter got shot from the turret I got my
part of the job done job done you got fight this
Hello?
This isn't the place.
Oh.
You gotta keep going.
This looked like the place.
It's similar.
Also, Altair, you're still muted, by the way.
You're just trying to talk to us.
This is the place.
Sorry, I didn't have time to unmute.
I was dodging for my life.
Oh.
All right.
What was that?
It's unloaded.
Oh, yeah.
Oh!
What is this?
What?
Drones!
Ah!
That's what it is, buddy.
Oh, there's the box, my favorite box.
It's probably okay.
I don't think so.
Okay.
I'm dead!
All right, I got a rubber pad.
Oh, that's a lot of items.
See, I told you, I gotta not stand in the middle.
I gotta wait.
Thank you.
There are a couple drones behind you guys.
There's a gun case behind me?
What's a gun case?
This?
Is this a gun case?
No, that's rubber parts.
No, we gotta leave it unlooted, guys, for this to work.
Alright, guys.
Hi.
I'm hiding.
If I get shot at you guys, you gotta come out.
hidden if the strat doesn't work because i don't know i
don't know we it worked we got it on the first go ahead so i
don't know if it's gonna work again back to back guys to
work i'll pretend to loot or something i'll be like i'll be
pretending to do it right here hurry start making sounds
yeah yeah help us pretending the loot right here so in case
what's this moss is that like what is this anyway collect
moss do i collect moss oh my god i do i guess that's what it
means yeah hello oh i could do not do not blow my fucking
cover out there shut the fuck up don't blow my cover right
now Oh, they're close.
Gun shots.
Very close.
Let me know if you were coming because I don't know the
actual sound for footsteps in this game.
They're close.
You might want to start talking in the general area.
Hello?
I feel so...
We're sick.
That confusion in her voice just so much.
She fains innocence too well.
Yeah, you like that?
Yeah.
It's called acting.
Well, I'm going to search this just in case.
Hey, battle.
Do you have any bandages left?
I don't hear anyone.
Are you sure people are going to come here?
I swear to God, you blow my cover out here after everything
we set up for.
We're being shot.
Hello?
Ain't no freaking way.
No way!
Hello?
Are you kidding me?
They're coming in.
Are you guys friendly?
Wait, are they...
I don't feel friendly.
I just killed this lady.
Wait, what?
Wait, there was a person here?
Guys.
I'm dead.
Wait, guys, don't kill me, please.
Wait.
Are they dead?
Can you let me up, please?
I just want to play with you.
Sorry, what?
No!
Like, I told you.
I told you that's jack's not going to work.
As soon as it went out, you slice me the head.
Are you kidding me?
I told you guys.
Okay, you fucking blew our cover.
You fucking, I'll take.
You fucking blew our cover.
Betel is mad now.
Betel is fucking mad.
Betel, I played my part.
I played my part.
Yeah, you did pay your part.
If I got a bandage, I'd be okay.
You did not need a bandage.
As soon as I step out and go loot something, they
immediately snipe me.
You did not need a bandage, bro.
Yeah, I don't think they're friendly, guys.
I need that bandage.
I got a one-shot, clearly.
I don't even have, like, a person to help use this, do the
strat.
Not to actually be friends with someone.
Now...
You could have been.
You gotta make me...
Oh, my God.
I gotta be friends with someone for real.
real guys maybe this doesn't work maybe we just no no my
part of the strat works my my the second half that's the
easy part this the execution of of my bait it's hard i bring
i bring people in but somehow they're still alive hmm you
didn't even bring them in they shot me from outside my cover
before if they saw just me everything would have been fine
it's fine it's fine i have nothing i'm trying to find a bush
to die in i would die in this bush all right are we trying
are we trying we can't do the i don't know do you think
third time the charm we gotta try one more time it's up to
One more time.
How stupid.
Try it again.
Look at my furry city.
I gotta bring a gun.
I'm bringing a gun.
I'm just saying.
time we did it it worked
oh yeah i know
i'm out of materials i'm losing all my stuff you're 50 hours
cried at least you're using it you're not wasting it right
right right oh i i Yep.
Hi, Hakka.
Does Hakka play this game?
I don't think so.
Betel is poor now.
Just like us.
Betel's poor.
Okay.
Deep breaths.
Let's do it again, guys.
Okay, okay.
All right.
I believe, I believe in the strat.
Okay.
The last try if it doesn't work.
It's not it worked on my end single inch.
I'm not making a single sound It worked on my end.
It's a success for me So okay, let me let me understand this
let me understand the protocol here So you lure them in and
you just want me and all terror to shoot the three gods Yes
Because you understand that we are still at a disadvantage
even if we get to jump on them You understand that right?
And then she runs away valiantly.
I did shoot my gun.
Are you going to shoot your gun?
I need to understand the situation that I'm going to be.
Now that I've realized that the two men I brought couldn't
finish the job, I shall also participate in the shooting.
Okay.
Good.
Because we kind of...
Yeah.
Okay.
No, we're good.
Yeah.
I'm just saying, like, you know, I didn't realize I had to
get my hands wet as well.
that blood i didn't realize i had to i had to get my hands
wet with the blood as well i didn't realize that i thought i
thought i just you know i was just i thought i was just
playing the mind games part you know i thought those hands
are about to be wet but blood by the time we're done with
the stream he's gonna kill us it's fine i didn't realize i
gotta also do more also didn't really I didn't realize that
I forgot gravity is a thing in this game.
It's so realistic.
Oh, there's people nearby.
They're real close.
I see them over there.
Okay, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Okay, you guys.
Are we gonna interact with these people or still go to our
house?
Well, we could try and intersect.
We're gonna arrive at the house.
They might be on the way there.
Oh, that's true.
That's true.
Do you want to go to the house?
That's where we get the jump on them.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Like sickos.
do like a leading strat like like move them slowly closer
closer yeah damn that's fucked up okay where's that voice
coming from help i'm in i'm in too don't fucking all right
you guys ready watch out for the oh what the coming okay
nice okay now they might walk in before you get to say help
and shit so just yeah let me know they're coming in and i'll
pretend to look i'm like standing here hello sorry for the
delay yeah all right now you actually hide okay i'm sitting
you actually hide this and i'm going to the bathroom okay
you're going to the bathroom where come in he's actually
going to the bathroom you're so close oh are you friendly oh
my god they look so cautious did they they've left what what
do you guys say he backed out immediately oh hello
leave they look at you they look at you and she immediately
moved out he's like girl i gotta leave bro he's like girl
and he's like it's a trap guys he's scared of women okay
just chill this is his first they did not want that heat
they they literally left wait who's that
oh i'm scared Are you guys okay out there?
Are you guys friendly?
Oh my god.
Oh Jesus.
Oh god.
I'm sorry, it's like perception.
I'm so scared.
Did we fucking mag dump this guy?
Are you guys friendly?
Yeah, yeah.
I don't know where the extraction is.
I've been really lost.
See us.
Don't know where the extraction is.
Yeah, I'm really lost.
I just my first time playing.
I've gotten a moral compass.
I can't do this anymore.
Finish it out, Fiddle.
You gotta get them over here.
I actually don't know where the extraction is.
Oh, they're just so confused.
I'm gonna collect fertilizer, guys.
Southwest, where?
Southwest?
Wait.
Where?
In between, in between Southwest and West upon top of you.
Oh, wait, what does that look like on my map?
Wait, does it show on my map?
Like, I feel like a tutorial doesn't really teach you how to
find the extraction.
Oh, we're horrible.
Oh, so just head like Southwest, like this way.
And then there's like an extractor.
Why did they take- This is the first time in here?
Yeah, no, this is my second game.
My friends kept telling me to play this game, so I tried.
I'm so confused.
Sorry, what do you say?
Sorry, the mic quality is pretty- Oh.
Look at this basket?
Okay.
Oh, they're too nice.
Oh, God.
Oh, thank you.
No problem.
Oh my god, bro!
Okay, okay.
They're in the woods that way.
Oh, okay, okay.
There's an extract that way.
Oh, thank you.
Thank you guys.
I don't want to do this anymore.
I don't like this anymore.
On your back.
Oh, okay, I see, I see.
This isn't what a hero does.
Yeah, it's in the middle of the woods.
Oh, okay, okay.
There's like some more stuff I didn't do over there.
You guys want it oh no it's all yours really good all the
good stuff yeah we're good oh thank you okay guys we can't
kill these guys okay oh okay oh thank you guys oh thank you
guys are way too nice you're
Like they gave me free they pride.
I'm sorry.
They pride me.
I got some good shit.
I got Good luck, Donkey Guys, I got some bro.
They got me some good shit though.
I
Did they that's good
Hey, okay, don't worry don't worry the second one we the
second group we bring in that i i'm sure the second one
won't be the nicest people on earth i can't wait the second
group but hey it works get prepared my part works i mean it
does you just got to get them over here on this side oh oh
hello oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh oh Yeah,
there's...
They're back, they're back, guys.
They're back.
Tell them to fucking get the fuck out of here.
I can't stand them anymore.
Wait, guys, I think there's people in here now.
Wait, and where?
No, no, I'm telling them.
Guys, I think...
She ratted us out.
She's running!
What do you mean?
We didn't lock their car.
What's going on?
there's like a oh i got blown up i got blown up oh wait what
happened park wait stay in position no no no there's i got
hit by a arc there's a guy no no i got hit by wait can they
res can the friendlies res or can they res what the is
happening we're horrible we're horrible you guys are
horrible people you guys are horrible people they're the
same group there are these them yeah No, no, just kill them.
Kill them.
Kill them there.
Whatever.
Yeah, it's fine.
I've lost the care.
You kill them now.
It's okay.
I got shot by an arc.
Wait, did you kill them?
No.
Uh, no.
Oh, okay.
They said it right.
One on our left, one on our right.
They just left.
I don't know.
I need to get Doki.
Yeah, yeah, get me over here.
I'm in this bush.
Yeah, they- no, they were fighting a big robot.
They're still fighting it, I think.
We're good.
That's fine.
Okay, guys, I think I'm still really growing a conscience.
Only think you three tries.
Here's the problem.
Growing a conscience in this game revolves around people
talking to you, because odds are they will talk to you, and
the second they do, they gain humanity.
Yeah, and they...
Oh, my.
I don't know, man.
They gave me free stuff, and I'm very easily bribable.
I think if they didn't give me free stuff, I don't think I
would have...
I think I would have let them die.
I don't know who I'm shooting.
I don't care anymore.
I don't know if it's conscience or like, or like, I just
like being bribed.
It could be one or the other.
It could be both.
Yeah, it could be both, honestly.
And if I do like, you can keep that, I'm like, oh, nice.
We killed one of them.
Oh, you killed one of them?
Wait, wait, are you?
Who are you?
Don't talk to him!
What about his fucking misery?
Wait, wait, wait.
I'll be like, are you friendly?
Are you friendly?
No, no, no.
I'll be, I'll talk over.
Wait.
Oh my god, I got hit by the rock.
I hate, I hate these goddamn arcs.
How do I pick you up?
Oh, oh, I found some.
Wait, don't kill them.
Don't kill them.
They're my friends.
Did I stabilize you?
Wait, wait, how do I?
Guys, the Rocketeers, you guys got to get the fuck out.
You can't be RPing with this guy.
He's your guy explode.
Don't kill them.
I'm out of ammo.
I'm sorry, buddy.
I'm sorry.
Battery.
Use a bandage.
I died.
No, I wanted to make it so that they think that we're not on
the same team together.
You gave us immunity.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
So like, oh, wait.
The rocket killed both of us.
So no, no, no.
This is a long Kong.
You don't understand.
It was more so like I was trying to make them think that I
found new friends.
friends and i saved their lives because because like i i
spared him fucking way so by me sparing sparing him he's
gonna remember guys i'm about to die michael gorgias michael
gorgias i have five seconds left and my plan will not work
if you let me die this thing's fucking chasing me you guys
it's my time to it's so this is my strat this was my
original strat i thought i think you'd like scared hello i'm
all alone hello okay so also did the guy like full dive
because of the rocket yeah oh okay so this was my original
strat i'd be like my initial plan was that i'd be like don't
kill him so they remembered that i spared them from their
deaths but then i'll be like guys oh i made these new
friends and be like oh i made these new friends and i in in
like um i'm helping you guys and then they'll be like oh
she's not associated with you two you know and because of
that they'll like trust us more because of it and yeah you
should fold that that way shot is up oh you think you're
being executed you're being executed look at that if you
went with my shot he would have picked you up i was going to
kill him and you said to I was literally five seconds away
from just killing this guy.
So I think you need to use two bandages to stabilize it down
to enemy player.
I think.
We need to, you know, you need a defibrillator.
No, no, no.
Guys, guys, I think the fourth try, we can do it.
Just trust me.
Like, I...
One more.
I think we can do it.
The fourth try.
I got it all set up.
That all.
I can...
I think we can do this.
I think we can do it.
We just need to not come across such nice people.
Yeah, yeah.
It's just that the fact that they bribed me at the end,
like, fucked me up.
Like, I was ready.
I was, like, you know, I was building their trust.
And then they bribed me.
And then, and then it fucked me up.
But if they don't bribed me, it'll be fine.
Okay.
I'm not lousy bait I fucking baited two teams it's just that
I was so convincing that I was so innocent that like they
were so trusting in me they were so trusting like they could
not see through the lies okay dokey dokey you need to get
them into the corner somehow so maybe ask them like, hey,
how do you open up this, this, this loop box?
Okay, no, then they know it's a fucking bait.
Like, the E button is right there.
Okay, okay.
Something a little bit different, then.
You should open up a shop.
I should be like, okay, okay, wait, I got the strat.
I got, I got, no, trust me, trust me in this.
I got a new, a new honeypot.
I got a new honeypot, like, crafted.
Okay.
There's in-game voice change.
Yeah, guys, no, Altair tried it and it was dog shit.
You need a real woman to do this.
I will concede there.
Boy, I am no woman.
I played plenty of Overwatch.
I know how to do this.
I've seen the ways in Overwatch, guys.
Hey, check out this dark and foreboding hallway.
I've encountered many players.
I'll tear my favorite woman.
Thank you.
I think.
I don't know.
I think Gavis Betel's my favorite woman.
How's the mood feeling, Betel?
Are you feeling okay?
Yeah, feeling good?
Are you feeling good?
Yeah.
Are you sure about that?
Fetel, fourth time to try.
The first time that it would have been perfect.
if we were succeeding in the first time.
We got a real bad spawn.
Oh, this isn't it, guys.
It's 18 minutes in.
And we got a bad spawn.
Oh, no.
No, it's fine.
It's fine.
It can still work.
Well, the gear still refresh itself.
Do you want to improvise somewhere else?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Let's improvise.
It's all about improvisation.
Improvision.
Battle, why do you have so many health bars next to your
health bar?
Because I put on the head.
be shield because I was getting ready for fucking goddamn
World War fucking 50.
The fourth time it'll be ready.
I believe.
Just think of all the loot we're gonna get when we succeed.
Just think.
We're gonna kill three guys with three loadouts.
No, no.
Three guys with all the loadout.
No, no, no.
This is it.
Okay.
Donky, I believe in you because if you ever lied to me, then
i'd be very very sad no no this is it this is i'll shoot my
gun this time i'll shoot my gun for real i got pharaoh i my
free loadout gave me a pharaoh okay so guys if you guys
didn't know that if you jump from this height you would die
oh it's it slid us all wait how do you get down from here
though uh try to try the same way we did honestly jumping
off work pretty well is it
Oh my knees Where the fuck is the ladder Oh my knees My
knees Water treatment elevator closes I was one second away
from Executing that guy but I stopped the timer It was like
Brain perfect Are you still mad but that guy stopped you
from executing?
Look my plan Would have been perfect if that rocket Didn't
come in front of us all right all right is that there's a
guy in there okay it's the rockets here oh okay oh this is
good this is promising it might be in here okay or around it
dokey can you check with your voice okay hello they're
inside hello is anyone there
fuck it time to improvise Who are people?
Friendly, I'm friendly.
Oh, you guys are friendly?
I'm friendly.
Wait, where's your team?
I'm solo, they all died, I'm friendly.
Oh, okay.
Alright, okay.
Bet'll do it.
You guys res me?
I thought you guys could res her.
Bet'll do it, bang, bang, bang, bang.
I looked away for one second.
I told you I can be heartless.
That felt good.
You like how I said...
With them, with them, with them, Toki.
If you like how I said...
Get someone outside.
Hello?
You like how I said okay?
You like how I said that?
I said okay.
I need that.
Alright, I got a lot of stuff.
There you go.
You can loot the rest.
She thought I was going to rest here.
Evil.
There's people nearby.
Okay, you guys got...
You guys need help out there?
Oh, Jesus.
I killed that guy too fast to give a shit.
Yeah, you did.
Hello?
They're not restored.
responding.
I think if they see a dead body here, they're gonna know I'm
not friendly, guys.
They're gonna know.
It doesn't disappear.
They're kind of behind that box.
I guess.
That's your teammate that died.
Yeah, what if that's their teammate?
No, she said, she said like all her teammates are dead.
No, that's your teammate.
Oh, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Oh, dad, you're cooking.
You're cooking right now.
You're gonna do a funeral for your teammate.
Alright, alright, alright, alright.
I was like, oh, I'm just really sad because my teammate
died.
Oh, I'll be like, oh, she had to go, so she, like, killed
herself.
Okay, okay.
Hello?
No, I don't think anyone's coming in.
Wait, was that?
Hello?
You guys hear that?
Was that someone there?
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, I'm sorry.
died she had to log off so I'm trying to get her stuff yeah
and I'm saying my friend my friend had to leave so I'm
trying to get her stuff right now no no she's dead she had
to surrender because like she had to log off so I'm trying
to make sure I get her stuff wait what does the D she's down
she's down oh you're down oh uh wait i think i do give me a
sec watch their watch them bait us oh are they baiting me i
don't know let's find out wait we're all right no no i'm
coming i'm coming i don't i'm running in front of you i'm
running from you to your right am i right okay i think
they're honeypotting us yeah you go out you go you go first
you go out you go out you go out look back behind you behind
your daddy oh oh oh come back inside oh there you are oh
wait how
Fabian, give me a sec.
That's good.
This is good.
See, I'm having fun now.
Go back to your spot.
Go back to your spot again.
Oh, a DeFi.
Yeah, a DeFi.
There's loot over here.
Yeah, yeah.
I don't want to move.
See, Ben, aren't you having fun now?
I like being the executioner of your fucking six sociopathic
plan.
person and then execute them.
Yeah, you like that?
Yeah.
You guys are horrible.
And for that, I'm turning on proximity chat.
Oh, wait, wait.
Yeah, you should have, no, you should have turned what they
were saying, really.
Well, it probably helps if the executioner doesn't hear what
they're saying, because I did not have a compass going up to
that person.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yeah, go.
Yeah, hide here.
I don't know how she died.
How the fuck does she die?
We have 10 minutes before we have to get the fuck out of
here.
Actually, we need to get out of here on, like, five.
Plenty of time.
Sure.
Actually, we should just go now.
Last extraction is over there.
Yeah, let's just go now.
Let's go now.
Let's get out of here.
We got two pieces of loot, guys.
See?
Improvise.
Even our honeypot plan changed, too.
Uh-oh.
It's women supporting women.
That person must have been so confused when a silent man
walked up behind.
person with dead teammates and executes them
it's like the weirdest thing imaginable it was just unlucky
guys that it was two other female players okay guys it would
have worked out it would have been the same it would have
happened the same way no matter what oh no not again what
it's the fucking rocketeer again oh no Oh no, it's...
There's something right above me.
Yeah, I see that.
And I am not turning around.
Oh.
Oh my god!
Oh, I went after me!
Why did you go after me?
Oh, because of what I did,
No, no, that's...
No, no, no, it's right.
No, I did some fuck the shit just now.
I did so fuck this shit.
I'm distracting it.
Not the karma gods If anything I'm surprised yo, you're
maxed up like I'm safe though, I think Oh, am I safe?
Those things are impossible to run away from yeah, they are
how do you survive that better You just run inside but
there's nowhere to run so you're kind of just fucked.
Yeah Yeah, I was gonna say like, yeah, sorry.
I wouldn't advise this better dude it's camping you yeah i
think you got can we not shoot it down it's gonna be tough
having good karma may help ah like ttt no i lived in the end
so i don't know i don't think that's true maybe the world
truly is unfair sometimes i live still thanks dude like we
like if anything i'll tear someone that shouldn't have been
shot down he did nothing The fact that Betta lives proves
that karma ain't real.
He was the executioner.
That's Betta.
That's Betta for you.
He's like the fire of fate somehow.
I don't know how he does that.
How do we go up?
I have more bandages.
Oh, God.
Okay.
Okay, there's people there.
We send me in, okay?
Okay.
You guys don't, don't shoot.
You send me in.
You send me in like a fucking, like a torpedo.
Yeah.
I got it.
You gotta find a way to trap the people.
The more I do this, the better I'm getting.
I'm better I'm at.
Oh, that's a good life skill.
Yeah, you saw how, you saw that last group we, like, I let
them go.
Like, they were so convinced of how naive and innocent I
was, even though I actually don't know where the extraction
point was.
You were technically telling the truth.
So not only are you killing them, you're also wasting their
time.
Yeah, I was wasting their time.
You guys like that?
And see, guys, I told you guys, like...
Maybe Doki shouldn't be part of the guild.
Guys, I told you guys that, like, people can be friendly
here.
To me, of course.
How does things still up?
Oh, no.
We didn't shoot the thrusters.
Yeah, you got to shoot the back of it because the front is
blocked a little, so it's got to be harder to take down.
Oh wait, is it up now?
Whoa.
That thing is trying.
It's one!
Oh, it's opening.
Wait, it's shutting down.
No, that's not ours.
That's not ours.
Oh, okay.
Another one.
Let's go.
Let's leave that alone.
50 guys we all made it yay we did it I told you four times
four times the charm four times the charm I told you we
improvised I told you guys look at that are you satisfied
now better yes I
Honestly, yes.
She got the kill a little bit.
It brought me so much joy shooting that person on the ground
with him.
Oh, man, you should have heard it.
You should have heard those two.
They really thought we were going to pick them up, too.
They really...
Yeah, that's fucked up.
I didn't feel good about that.
They...
I smell amazing.
Oh, no.
All right, I'm ready.
I'm ready.
I love this game.
Huh?
New destination available.
Blue gate, yeah.
A good one.
Okay.
That's a good one for when we actually want to play the game
instead of social experiments.
Wait, not enough space in your stash.
Manage your inventory.
Oh, I have too much items now.
So you can expand your stash with money.
Oh, do I have money?
See how much money I have.
I have 5,000.
You might be able to expand it once.
Yay!
All right, I'm ready.
Reload out.
Let's go.
Get one second.
No karma, too.
Look at that, guys.
No karma.
Is that a good thing or a bad thing?
I got finished a stream and get hit by a bus.
I was like, okay, Beto, you can do it.
After I told her, like, yeah, I'll pick you up.
Damn.
I can't repair this Okay Good to go, sorry I think that
person Must have been so confused when they saw it When I
said like, oh I'm just helping my friend pick up her loot
And then she saw three of us walk out And you're like Wait,
I thought your friend was gone You're evil Do it The thing,
we had like four Defibs, so we could have picked everybody
up Yeah, but we got to We can't look at that statistic, my
friend.
If we used that DFib, we would have had three DFibs out
there.
Like, what the fuck is wrong with you?
You're right.
Women are always right.
It's like Betel is the person.
Doki is the devil on the shoulder.
I'm the angel on the shoulder.
You're barely an angel.
You were a bisexual.
You know, like the bystander effect?
You let this happen.
I'm an angel.
You're just as bad as I am.
You are just as bad as both of us.
You're an angel too, Beto.
No, he's not.
I'm not.
He's like...
He's like Adam.
I'm Adam.
You're Adam.
He is Adam.
I'm like, you bite that apple, Adam.
You're the serpent.
Yeah, yeah.
The newest bad apple cover came up.
You know you wanna
Why are you making him eat an apple Then Good spawn, good
start And our creators Are we doing it again?
Wait, do we not want to do it?
Did it inspire you to do it one more time?
I don't know what we were doing I don't know Let's just play
We play now No, we play now We play now We'll improvise
We'll improvise Oh fuck, I'm not ready now cute people.
Oh, wait, did you bring stuff?
Did you, oh, you're out?
Okay, well... I'm geared to the teeth.
All right, let's go, let's go.
Okay, we'll do it.
We'll do it.
We're in a good place, right?
It actually makes much sense that we just, yeah, I mean,
it's a good spot.
We don't have to do it.
No, no, let's do it.
Let's do it.
You got your shit, let's go.
Okay, they're being the serpent.
You got that high.
I think it's pretty early into the round, 28 minutes.
I mean, we're here.
Yeah, Bedo bit the apple and now he can't stop.
I'm addicted.
He's chasing that high again.
He's chasing the high.
Fertilizer.
Watch, and I got to turn on voice chat, and they're going to
see the worst thing imaginable now when this works.
This is the one time.
I bet you this is going to be the time that it doesn't work.
Like, already get started.
This is going to be the place where it doesn't work, guys.
Doki, the sociopath, battle the psychopath, altered.
No concept of what morality is.
You're the bystand.
You're the bystander.
have stopped it but you did it i could have stopped it
you're right i could have i'm having fun though and is that
so wrong i'm having a lot of fun i'm gonna breach this and
then pretend i'm just looting this for the first time
pretend you're hot micing oh yeah oh that's true that's true
i'll be like oh my god have like a dog barking in the
background Let me know you guys hear people coming or not.
Yeah, because I still don't understand footsteps in this
game.
I just hear things blowing up.
Oh, it's just...
You should talk like that.
Hello?
That's east, directly east.
Or is it here?
Not too close, but it's getting there.
Okay, I'll just be.
Hello?
You guys like that voice.
It's so innocent.
hello it's so innocent hello
i'm gonna get shot i'm gonna get pop pop instantly i feel it
i feel like this is this is the run where it's not gonna
it's finally not gonna work would that be the karma yeah
this is the karma i'm ready i'm ready to get headshot right
here when it was that same group we shot like the first the
first snap we ever bumped into the group and like oh you're
not you're not getting away this time and then they get
tricked again absolute cinema right there i'm pretending to
loot this one place this one area right here yeah i'm
getting bored oh now you're getting no no you gotta chase
that high we gotta give altera chance to execute he's gonna
he's gotta get that person you see yeah yeah i don't know if
i could do that that's gonna change me fundamentally it's
called a bird leave in the nest no no i don't want to fledge
i don't hear anyone are you guys is this place like the best
place for loot
sometimes where the heck are our people depends what you
want i want a big sandwich nobody's here
set it's so quiet shots you know like the south it's so
quiet so yeah it could just be a could just be a dead lobby
for this place we could we could leave and play normally up
to you guys is that what you want better are you i got what
i wanted i got to excuse someone in cold blood i like that
so i'm done i'm satisfied are you sure do you not want to
are you sure you're it again feel that you're not feel that
rush of adrenaline are you not what if we did what if we did
our arc raiders until we win there's no winning in arc
raiders what the are you talking about endurance stream
until we win i've already won yeah you're playing with us
yeah yeah see you're you're getting the new stress you know
you were you were playing arc raiders wrong the entire time
i'm bringing you the new strats here the the new the bait
the man kill him well i couldn't do this i mean i could do
this solo but now that i have like company to be copable
with in my horrible deeds so this works for me exactly i'm
surprised this is the longest no one has ever shown up here
maybe like word got around about us don't trust this house
30 minutes yeah
a woman say hello don't go in that room woman are fake woman
are illusions do not go into that house don't dad woman
inside and it's like specifically they circled the map the
area and on the map too yeah they made a reddit post about
us in the last hour that we did this the ground firing at
war going on but maybe this is the real war
i don't hear anything that's crazy this is like the longest
that no one is we can dip wait wait i'll we'll wait two more
minutes guys two more minutes going at high spa i trust if
two minutes nobody show up we leave the sirens retiring off
to the east and the south i'm with i'll tire here or or we
could after two minutes we improvise again improvising was
pretty good i really want to breach this and search it but
someone was like you're not even looting it's because we
have to keep it yeah i have to make the illusion that i just
started looting this place so they'll go deeper in all right
don't worry we have one minute left that's crazy i i think i
will I'm pretty sure the Reddit, there is a Reddit post
about just now.
I'm starting to believe the Reddit post because it's crazy
that we've been here for like six minutes or eight minutes
and nobody showed up.
Eight minutes?
Yeah, this is like every time someone has showed up, nobody
has showed up this time.
No, you don't say I'm friendly.
You say, are you guys friendly?
Because I'm friendly is more suspicious.
that's true yes see see that's how you gaslight people oh my
god there's a rocketeer right above us there's two
rocketeers who yeah if you look up why do you keep bringing
us to this place battle it's the best spot to hide wait so
like what's a dead lobby well it's not dead lobby It's just
like people are just avoiding this spot because it's just
random.
Oh, I see.
All right.
We leave.
We it's time.
All right.
Come on.
Let's go.
Die by other means.
All right.
Let's go.
What if like someone shows up after we leave this place?
We might be fucked up.
Etoki, you don't have to put those thoughts in my head.
I feel sad now.
You feel sad that you couldn't kill them?
Yeah.
I wanted my turn.
Rocketeers sensing the evil inside Hey guys, we didn't even
loot that place guys What the fuck We just Chat, you don't
understand The joy is not looting this place The joy is Lurr
baiting people in there That's where we get our joy
Hello?
Altair is not Hello?
Who's in here?
What do we roll play as if we're like, not even part of the
same team?
Oh, hey!
Hey, who are you?
I'm friendly, I'm friendly!
I'm friendly!
Why are you guys stealing my stuff!
Don't shoot, I'm friendly, guys!
Wait, there's someone outside.
There's someone outside!
Oh, what?
Wait, I'm hiding.
I'm hiding?
Don't give a.
Hello?
Is someone at the front door?
Hello, are you guys friendly?
God damn it.
Of course it suits me.
Wait, wait, wait.
Hello?
Oh my god, wait, they're not coming in.
I'm scared.
They're finding Ark.
Oh, wait, I'll help them.
He was right at the door.
You guys need help outside?
Oh.
I don't know.
Hello?
Oh, here's another...
There's two more arcs outside.
Do you guys need help?
They're not saying anything.
They said something in this stop.
What the fuck?
They probably read this Reddit post.
I think they're gonna shoot me, guys.
They don't seem very close.
They are?
Oh, no, they're not.
They were at this entrance right here.
We're going to go to the domes.
You guys need help?
There's someone inside.
Someone inside.
Are you guys friendly?
Your friend?
What?
Friendly?
Go to him.
Sorry, I can't hear you.
You're up, dude.
Are you guys friendly?
Sorry, I can't hear you.
Don't crack.
I'm not cracking.
I'm pretending.
I'm scared.
I'm scared they're gonna shoot me.
No.
They're never gonna shoot you.
That's cute.
You'd be like, hello?
Hello?
Where did he go?
Did he leave?
I don't know.
Wait, I think he left.
Yeah, I think he left.
Bro, that guy's gone.
That guy's gone, gone.
Well.
All right, back to looting.
Back to looting.
That guy left.
Bro, what the fuck?
He was like, you...
That guy was a pussy.
He didn't fall for the bait.
We saw 18 minutes left.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
They're like, fuck that shit.
This is a trap right here.
Some bullshit.
That's some bullshit.
Women aren't real.
Woman play my FPS game.
Yeah, he's like, no way.
Women are real.
This is a trap right here.
Hey.
Wait.
Did I hear something?
Hello?
Oh, someone's extracting?
Okay, it's fine.
Man.
I'm fucking looting.
My favorite spot.
Whoa, I got a pink!
What?
Okay.
Yay!
I don't have a free pocket this time no I don't have a safe
pocket no oh my god see I'm rewarded you guys okay I swear
to deserve that
they're hit ow
right side there's two on the right one there's no there's
no karma you gotta leave with that loot yeah i deserve that
i deserve that was that that's karma right there that's
actual karma that's oh that's actually beautiful karma Are
you down?
Let's keep running, keep running, keep running.
Dude, I'm slow.
Oh, it says you have too much loot?
I got a big shield on.
I finally did not get away with it.
Bro, you're dead, Altair.
You're so dead.
You're so dead, Altair.
I'm not dead.
I'm never dying.
Heroes never die.
Justice always prevails.
Did I learn my lesson?
No.
God damn Ark, man.
All right, we got- and you died to the Ark, man.
Uh-oh.
There's someone inside.
hello are you guys part of the war
i don't think he wants to talk to you that guy was actually
part of the war he said he was part of the war oh he was
part of the war i don't even know what the war it is oh man
what's the evasive carnage invasive what is this the evasive
clan the fuck is this clan Like, how the fuck is this an
evasive clan?
Is that the war?
Is that the war names that they use?
They put, like, a war tag?
Wait, chat, is that actually what they're called?
Oh, I don't know.
I don't even know.
But you literally have a clan tag called evasive.
Do you want a clan tag?
Wait, what is our clan tag?
All right, now we play for real.
yeah we weren't trying last time now i'm ready to play for
real i had fun now that i got karma i'm ready to play for
real okay i'm using a free load out now we're playing for
real where are you gb i gotta make ammo one second
it took two hours of warm-up
i don't even know what the the team names are for this
fucking war no idea yeah you know now that i know now that
now that i have my fun time we'll give better his fun time
better what oh no this is fine this is fine it's fine how
much did you trust this how much did you lose oh i mean on
the stream yeah a lot but you're having fun though right
yeah yeah that's all i like having fun that's all we're
trying to do yeah terrorize you and make you have fun i mean
you haven't done the strap before so i showed you a new
strat that's true i wish i had as diabolical stress you guys
wait what if we what if we merge it again no we're not doing
what we'll do happy birthday Because that's what Betel's
doing.
We'll celebrate happy birthday.
We'll be like sitting happy birthday in the room and then
they'll join They'll join us.
No, no.
We'll do that randomly.
We'll just pop my kid and we'll be like, bro We'll be like
having a fake conversation be like, bro, isn't it today your
birthday, man?
What's your birthday?
No, yeah, no, it's Betel's birthday.
It's Gorbius birthday, remember?
Oh, dude.
Happy birthday, Gorbius.
I didn't know it was your birthday.
We should have a happy birthday song for this guy.
Dude, how old are you turning 35?
Yeah.
Yeah, already?
50?
Stop push it.
So we'll have like a fake conversation, like an open mic
fake conversation.
Open mic fake.
We're transforming this again.
We're creating a new bit.
So what are you going to do for your birthday, Michael?
Yeah, Michael, what are you going to do for your birthday?
Get away from me!
Happy birthday to Michael.
I got a loot thingy.
Yeah, oh yeah, we should all like open mic this.
So like guys guys, I'm turning to open my gun I'm gonna
hurry up.
I'm gonna turn fake open mic Michael it's your birthday.
Yeah, Michael, Michael, we got something for you.
It's your birthday.
Oh, is there not an opener thing?
Wait wait, are you?
What are you planning on doing for your birthday, Michael?
Oh, you're going to Sabrina Carpenter concert?
That's awesome.
No, I said what are you gonna do for your birthday, bro?
I got you got party.
Yeah?
Oh, shit.
Your mom planned you a party.
Aw.
Bro.
Laser tag.
Yeah, laser tags with the homies.
Oh, we should go laser tag.
Yeah, that's fun.
Bro, that's sick.
Is your dad coming along?
I heard, like, you know, you're in like...
Yeah, ever since they left.
Yeah, you know, after your son's your dad and your mom.
Get away from me!
Go!
Well, at least you get two birthdays, right, bro?
Yeah, happy birthday!
Happy birthday.
to Michael.
Happy birthday to Michael.
Happy birthday dear Michael.
Yeah!
I have a fun time playing this game, guys.
Okay, we only have to repeat that 17 more times.
Yeah, we just gotta do that 17 times.
Okay, don't say that on...
Okay, wait, turn it off.
You have to do fake open mic We gotta pretend we're
open-miking it.
Like, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay.
It's a well-rod, buddy.
That's only if you're one shot.
All right, all right.
Yo, guys, have you guys checked out that new game that just
came out last week?
Oh, which game?
No, not Arc Raiders.
You know that other one.
Bro, that game sucks.
Come on.
Oh my god, wait, wait, yeah, oh guys, do you hear about the,
the, uh, what Faze Clan is doing right now?
But I was watching their streams today.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Should we watch him face?
Yeah, of course, face up, bro.
Face up.
Dude, I want to be part of face, but only Optic took me, so
I'm Optic.
Oh, you're into Optic?
Are these, do you still have streamers in Optic?
Did you just humegalome?
Okay, let's extract.
Happy birthday.
come on guys so here there's great loot at the hydroponic
dome there is wait what present oh my gosh i hope there's no
one there you think it'll be friendly guys i'd sure hope so
because i am a pacifist yeah me too bro i mean like be fair
i don't think we're not really that good at the game so like
that's really how we can play yeah like we probably lose if
we fought but that's okay because it's your birthday right
yeah it's your birthday michael birthday to michael Happy
birthday to Michael Happy birthday dear Michael Happy
birthday to you Yeah!
Yeah!
Happy birthday Michael!
It's his birthday guys!
Guys, three, two, one, go.
Oh god!
Oh Jesus, you're right!
This is a fuck-up.
They are a fuck-up.
Oh my god.
Oh god.
Sorry, this was...
Sorry, that was his birthday present for him.
I'm sorry, bro.
Oh god.
I wasn't ready.
It worked!
I only got cursed at.
He was like, I hope your birthday sucks.
Did you hear that?
My frickin'.
We're horrible.
Ouroblo.
Improvisation.
I told you.
That one felt real bad.
It went really, really bad.
That was fun.
That was so fun.
I have a  Principle.
We can't do that anymore.
That was so fun.
I'm still going to do it first.
Altair is the evil one.
Now he's coming down.
Dude, I tried just to see if I would like it.
I didn't like it.
I loved it.
I know he loved it.
Yeah.
I love that you was like I hope your birthday sucked And I
was like And I was like sorry bro That was his birthday
present Yo Michael it's your birthday soon huh Michael I
heard it was your birthday today Oh that was real bad Happy
birthday Michael Oh you guys picked them clean Jesus Christ
I told you it worked Improvising guys.
That was real bad.
We did a bad thing.
We're bad people.
Where are you guys going?
Is it at the extraction?
I don't know.
I don't know where I'm going.
I saw a ping.
You want to extract?
Yeah, let's extract.
No, no, no.
I want to extract.
I'll just, all right, let's go.
Oh,
god, that was real bad.
Dude, we have to get community service out of this man.
That was worse than like people trying to help out like in
gaming wise.
Those guys wanted to join in on a bit.
That was like those guys were my people.
We killed my people.
Those guys were like- They're never gonna trust people again
because of you.
Those were good people.
They're gonna start hating the birthday every single time.
The next year comes around, it's your birthday dude.
Oh, I remember when that guy killed me in our graders.
Yeah.
You guys want to do it again?
Sure.
Yeah, yeah.
Hey, guys.
Oh, my God.
It's your birthday today, bro.
Dude, birthday extract.
Stay away from me.
Bro, it's your birthday, bro.
You don't want to see happy birthday.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Michael.
Happy birthday.
to you
this is your birthday gift michael you killed two people
someone called it the trojan cake
i told you that plan will work pretending to open mike who
did we kill who did we kill bro i'm like figuring out like
all the new strats in this game guys i don't want to i don't
learn their names don't even tell them how do i tell how do
you tell press tab press tab you had confetti in his name
wait wait where is it oh i oh rasta rasta i killed rasta oh
i'm gonna look at his profile i'm gonna look at his profile
i'm gonna hide i want to know the man i killed what a fucked
up day oh his name is brandon you killed we killed brandon
Brandon!
We killed Brandon.
Sorry, Nock.
That was fun.
I think I like this game.
I got pink out of him too.
I got a pink out of Rasta.
Got a pink?
Yeah.
From that guy.
I should kill some more people like that.
Easiest pink of mine.
See?
Karma's not real.
I got back the pink I lost.
Karma's a bee.
And I shouldn't have known.
i actually got i i got back to pink i lost guys i got padded
stock all light ammo medium i got it again oh and a key wait
i got a key what's the key what's the key better huh i got
buried i got buried city hospital key oh that's good right i
don't i Yeah, you can open up.
It's like a secret place so you can get like good loot.
Oh.
See, guys?
Karma ain't real.
I think I got an upgrade of what an upgrade, basically.
What I lost.
Okay, let's play for real this time.
LG, real game.
Let's do it.
Oh, okay.
Let me, let me, let me loot up then for an LG.
Let me check my, let me check my stuff.
Let me check my stuff too.
I'm going to make a bigger shield.
Oh, what?
I should make a bigger shield too.
Why are you copying me?
That's fucking right.
I will I will work circuitry I hit my head hurts.
I have like I have like Moral damage that was crazy You
having fun?
I'm having fun.
Yeah, in ways that you probably did not think would happen.
Yeah Nonetheless, it's been a good time good Okay, I'm
ready.
We had to change my back how do i change my bag oh with the
oh it was this okay i got safe pocket now okay i'm ready
let's do it but i am going kind of good yeah i'm totally
good guys totally me too oh hold on what happened i
accidentally used free load up hold on oh wait i want to
cancel too okay i won't put my attachment stuff on it
where's my attack cool ass attachments oh extended
compensator or silencer common silencers are good i don't
have any attachments guys no attachments wait is that why
people have trust issues because of you in general or or
like in this game why do you think i have trust issues this
happened to me i was like walking to people yeah i streamed
this someone was going like hey hey how are you i'm like hi
and i walked down a hallway and they had mine set up and i
exploded they shot me to death i got a woman's strategy that
is a woman's strategy that's good i'm gonna take that
strategy my man
who's the other guys that battle um it looks like him
doesn't it Let's see.
What do I make?
He's kind of a sock pop.
Oh, I don't have any gear.
Okay, yeah, yeah, I'm ready.
Let's go!
This gives me so much joy.
Like, I'm not here to play the actual gun game here.
You want to play the psychological game?
Yeah, I'm here for the psychological warfare.
That is fun.
Yeah.
Let's go!
Look at the squad.
RGPB.
Regis.
Gavis.
I wonder what happened to their third guy.
They got...
Do we, like, merge with Solos, or is just all three stacks?
Always with three stacks.
Oh, their third guy died somewhere.
Because we only had to witness that one, too.
No, we just had to kill it.
We killed two because their third guy didn't show up.
up maybe because i believe it's always with three it used to
be like with a mixture but they changed it yeah so like
because i was like where was their third guy maybe the third
guy was so paranoid about us like he died probably oh yeah
or he died i'm thinking i think he just died because like
why wouldn't he sing the birthday song with us maybe maybe
well yeah maybe oh apparently dude oh dooku is bugged it
right now or something oh yeah so like Sometimes the duo
queue comes in.
I love the guy.
You know, that guy, the guy that's like, I hope your
birthday sucks.
That one was, I love that part.
Chad, did you even hear that?
You got a fun one.
The other guy just cursed at me.
Oh, shit.
The other guy just said, F you.
The fact that they still thought it.
Rightfully so.
I mean, the fact that they even believed the lie that it was
your birthday to after we killed them.
Happy birthday.
That was pure evil.
That was the worst thing today.
So far.
I'm gonna...
Okay, now it's my turn for fun.
What's your turn for fun?
We're gonna kill everyone.
The most evil thing we've done so far.
In fact, probably the most passive and regular.
At least I didn't emotionally toy with them.
I realize why people are like, don't shoot, don't shoot.
And they just start shooting.
But, like, I take it another level.
It's like people who finally play Shaco and League of
Legends.
I build an entire lore.
An entire story behind it.
We've been streaming this, too.
And everybody saw our shame.
Yeah, I'm adding roleplay to it.
It makes it more believable.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday dear Michael Michael Gorgias This is a hot
song Oh shit Whoa whoa whoa oh no she didn't wait wait wait
wait Wait wait no Oh they're not friendly They were not
friendly guys They were absolutely not friendly They were
not friendly It was a bye.
I should have been executed you.
Yeah, no, I left.
I had no actual loot, so I'm fine.
Oh, that guy crouched.
Oh, he slid.
Guys, this was a real game.
I died.
Karma.
Guys, it's not karma when it was free loot, guys.
I didn't bring actual loot.
Oh my god, he's doing it.
Oh, yeah.
Okay.
Oh my god, he's fracking.
He's fracking.
No!
You were so close!
Goodbye, Michael.
Wait, those are peanuts men?
Say it your birthday.
Oh.
Damn.
Oh!
Oh, we accidentally walked into the war zone.
Bro!
This was apparently the fucking area where everyone is
fighting, bro.
That's the war zone?
This was the war zone.
We just actually...
You took us to war!
Bro, he took us to the streamer war zone.
Is there an area where they do, like, they fight?
Yeah, apparently, my chat was like, bro, that was the war
zone.
Okay, but what if we were that birthday over there, too?
They actually think we were, like, the other side.
yeah yeah so i was like that was the whatever the bunta
later whatever it's called it's a big war between two big
claims yeah i was like why aren't they talking yeah they
don't give a those are those are war men yeah i got that's
one of the yeah we actually literally stumbled on it yeah no
civilians in the war zone guys want to do another i see we
do it that was that doesn't count that doesn't count okay
that one was like an actual war zone that we actually
accidentally walked into stumble upon yeah i mean we could
go back and just join i was really just supposed to go
around they definitely did not care about your birthday
that's for sure they they were going nuts But I don't know
what's the faction uniforms.
We don't know what the uniforms are, so we each are one of
the colors just in case.
Oh, so all die.
I think we're all, I think the only one wearing the right
uniform.
I think Altair is wearing a uniform of one of the factions.
Oh.
Uh-oh.
I'm pretty sure.
So they saw Altair.
I am the owner of the faction.
Dun, dun, dun.
all right this is lg as long as we didn't stumble into the
war zone okay we were literally like we were like
journalists we were journalists and they like fucked us up
oh i got a rattler i didn't i got a kettle you want it i'll
give you my kettle for your Rattler.
Really?
Yeah.
I don't fucking know what I'm doing.
Grab your ammo.
It's a three hours, Doki.
Oh, what was the gun?
The yellow ammo.
The yellow?
Okay.
Yeah.
Yellow gun for a yellow Doki.
Yellow.
What do Doki birds eat?
Food.
I knew it.
I'm sorry.
I even asked.
I'm trying to make conversation.
I am having a conversation.
Is that answer not good enough for you?
Oh, I'm sorry.
I gotta save my head for the rope there.
It isn't.
No, it's not good enough.
You asked the most fucking basic question ever.
Yeah, I'm sorry.
Okay, fine then.
It's like asking me how- What is the circumference of your
left nostril?
It's like asking me like, how's the weather up there?
You know?
How's the weather down there?
Oh yeah, fuck you.
I hope you get killed first.
Wee!
Doki, are you a girl, a tomato, or a bird?
Let's go do the- I could be both.
I listed three, but okay, that works too.
Guys, we can go- there's the- the domes are available.
Yeah, sure, let's get out.
Well, we can go there as warriors.
Guys, is this a war zone?
Oh yeah, okay.
Warriors.
Yeah, no no more- no more hanging out.
Let's get the silly ha-ha's out of the way.
Yeah.
No more psychological warfare.
This is physical.
club now this is real war the real deal the real game
serious we're real happy birthday okay now he's gonna die
your system he's gonna up for all of us we're good now watch
this i'm watching you check this one oh you did you took
that i'm i'm i'm zooming yeah you're I'll close the door
because I'm polite.
Oh, are you?
Okay, they said avoid control tower.
There's no control tower here.
I know where the control tower is.
Do you have a key for it or?
No, they said the control tower is one of the war zones.
Oh, yeah, that place is a shit show.
We could go there, but...
No, they said that's where the streamer wars are.
Okay, yeah, that's where we were earlier, like, outside of
the control tower.
So...
Let's move to that location.
oops sorry so yeah we're not going there guys i got bad news
what my mouse just died oh that's pretty that's never
happened before that's that's pretty bad is that my head
also died during this stream oh i think karma's coming for
us guys why do you have wireless everything dude i think
because it's sufficient that's true that's true because you
can no it's true because you can like walk walk downstairs
to grab like a drink or something that's right i can hear
what people talk a shit about me when i leave yeah yeah yeah
or you're going to a bathroom and you can listen to you can
listen in oh it's here watch out well well well what do we
have here oh hey just like old times guys just like old
times welcome to dome welcome to the dome is he look is this
thing How do you say?
That's sounding very suspicious.
Oh, he is not fine.
Bro greeted.
They're so greedy, bro.
What can I say, man?
I'm here for all the loot.
All the money.
All the loot and the money.
I keep forgetting the alt key is there.
Okay, now I realize why you don't like this gun.
Do you want the other one back?
No, no, that's cool.
I understand now.
I understand.
Drone, drone, drone!
Oh, what is it doing?
Oh, okay.
Happy birthday to me.
What if it's my birthday?
Killer.
Oh, that's messed up, bro.
No, that's messed up.
You can do it to me on my birthday.
I would never.
what is that i don't even know what's good in here like i
don't even know what i'm holding on to at this point yeah
for when you're starting off just pick the pretty colors
blue better than green okay i can repair shields let's go uh
blue i'll get rid of all the greens then You could probably
keep them.
But if you find more blues, you can always replace it.
Oh, I see.
I mean, that's not usually the rule of thumb, but just for
like right now in time, you may as well just get the best
stuff.
You're not supposed to say this place again.
You're supposed to say, oh yeah, this place again.
Yeah.
Not in a bad way, in a good way.
Oh, I should have got the ammo.
Oh, well.
I don't need the ammo.
I have 56, 59 bullets.
That's all I need.
I'm gonna have trauma on that little hill where we murdered
those men.
Yeah, that was a wonderful hill.
Happy birthday to you.
It's got the birthday hill where all your dreams come true.
Or birthday hell.
All your dreams die.
I didn't say whose dreams are coming true.
Definitely mine.
It's only mine.
Well, I'm full up on inventory.
yeah there's a water pump here an explosive compound okay
camelons i think i made an ante this guy's gonna look me up
this guy's gonna look me up
i'm more worried about the vtuber named michael gorbius he's
gonna get flamed okay you're the reason my name is not gavis
you're the one you're the one that keeps telling about
vtubers you're the one you're the one doing that what if
michael gorbius was a vtuber and and bettle's just
slandering his good name yeah guys if you see a jokie bird
and arc raiders that's an imposter i don't play that game
that's not me guys that was an imposter using a voice
changer i do not play arc raiders someone stole my name and
is personating me right now shots go east yeah sorry up
there it's up top yeah oh i'm too heavy i am not i'm fine my
items suck do we want to fight people sure i think we can
take them yeah we can do it we're not necessarily in the
position to be doing that this is our lg we gotta make it
work okay we may as well we gotta send die heroes wow and we
spend the entire stream villains um the winners the winners
write the history books and we die as heroes as long as we
repent at the very end and say I'm sorry as long as I go to
confessional right after sorry I didn't mean it but I said
I'm sorry I learned from my crimes I know what I did wrong I
know I'm forgiven.
But all is forgiven.
It's close.
It's real close.
I see them.
I saw bullets.
I'm a little bit far from you guys.
Isn't the Rattler really bad for last two?
I'm looking right at them.
I'm not gonna shoot yet.
Oh, they're fighting.
They're fighting.
Another two.
Wait, we can help this guy.
Let's wait until one's down and then we go in.
Where are we helping?
I don't know.
Not that guy.
Oh, not that guy.
Oh, I'm dead.
I'm dead.
Okay.
You didn't specify who we're helping, bro.
Well, I was just still assessing the situation.
I'll let you know they're pushing.
They're taking an awful angle to the left.
He's going behind the building.
Okay.
You could probably get us up.
Oh, he got you up.
I don't know if I can deal here.
Oh, uh...
No, pedal!
And I'm safe.
to hurry damn he was not safe guys he was not safe at all
this guy's below guys um no he was across i see the other
guy to my left right now he's assessing the situation too i
don't know if i should yeah no there's dude there's two
there's two should we fall back there's two over there um
yeah loot me look me yeah loot him loot him they're both
just chilling there I don't even know if I can like get out
of here Oh He's taking another cross Oh they're running
Right in front of you Oh my god I didn't see you but Over
there Oh Oh Turkey Yeah Southwest South close to us Oh
I see him I see him Ping Like I saw something Blocking Oh my
god it's it's the arc i got shot by a player though yeah
yeah i know i know but the arc looked at me no not the arc
epic arc moment epic arc moment no guys i think this game
would have been more fun if it's just pvp don't go don't go
don't go i hold the same opinion but people shut on me when
i say reactions.
I just like the PvP.
Watch out.
Let's fall back.
Bro, I have one HP.
I'm one HP.
There's no falling back.
I'm done.
Alright, bro.
Okay.
Another game.
That can't be our LG, but that can't be our LG.
We can do one more.
Okay.
I believe.
One more.
Yes.
One more good distraction game might be a while is that is
that too much is that too a bit too much to ask for is that
little just a little bit too much to ask for it last one no
matter what i gotta i gotta eat some dinner all right last
one no matter no matter what no matter what don't worry i
got you i'm putting on my combat box now oh shit i'm yeah
yeah i'm putting real guns in here i'm getting my you guys
want to go to a new map for the last one yeah yeah sure yeah
yeah yeah i'm getting you know i've grabbed two guns in here
too that's right dangerous that's right i ain't around this
time guys i'm taking a sniper rifle and nothing else oh
that's a light it was lame no i said oh i said i actually
put a light gun but i didn't need it oh i need my shield
i've got no guns what are you poor right now or some shit?
No.
Shut up.
What happened?
You die over and over?
Yeah.
God.
Shut up.
Bro, I thought you were a gamer, bro.
Yeah, well.
What happened?
Overwatch.
I'm ready.
I need some light ammo.
One second.
I'm ready.
I got natural loadout now.
All right.
let me just make a couple of things this is fun though guys
yeah i see this game so far i get the hype except for the
arc part i get the hype the interaction's been fun uh okay
almost done sorry sorry okay we're going to the map with the
most arc on it but it's more open so it's a little less hell
but what did we just say we hated the arcs yeah i like i
like this map it's more open it's it it has more arc but
it's a little it feels a bit better oh i see you know i
might be worried for saying this but i actually like better
than pvp how do you upgrade your gun better how do we
upgrade you can just you can just right click it and there's
an upgrade option and you just need the materials that it
asks for oh i could have done that oops
oopsie i was like the arc part is great but you can damage
people yeah but for some reason um the finds us first before
we can even do that.
Oik.
Okay.
All right, for real.
This is a real open map, but it's my favorite.
Uh-huh.
I'm still loading in.
Bro, y'all get an SSD, bro.
My SSD only has 30 gigabytes left on it.
I called it the big SSD, and now it's full.
Why don't you just install two SSDs?
I think I actually have to in both of them are full.
Wait, you have it already or you want to?
I think I have three SSDs.
Bro, all of them are full.
What the fuck are we trying to like fucking NASA space
computer?
One of them is 250 gigabytes for the windows.
One of them is for games and one of them is for stream
stuff.
What do you have?
How much do you have in there that's just stream stuff?
I take a lot of images in the HoloLive app.
are you still bro did you buy like a cheap ssd or some shit
how much space is in there 250 gigabytes oh yeah no that's
not yeah that's not a lot bro you gotta buy yeah that's
that's on you that's actually on you but i also filled up my
other two terabyte ones yeah and you should have got another
terabyte i'm too old for this i can't i can't do this
newfangled solid state drives you're gonna complain about
old yeah yeah when i'm here bro wait do you have a hard oh
is does your pc have a hard drive pedal it used to be um i
just got a new pc but i used to have hdd constantly for like
10 years yeah i would have like an hard drive and an ss and
an ssd and then like yeah and then people made fun of me and
i got peer pressured in it yeah yo just yeah yeah see peer
pressure works bro everyone was mean to me and they said are
you stupid and i'm huh and then they're like get this and
then i yeah and then you're like i don't want to be stupid i
don't want to be stupid anymore yeah and then i'm like look
i got it and they're like well you're still stupid yeah
you're still stupid for having a hard drive a cat bed oh
shit that is that's the best that you ever got i remember
when i found a rubber ducky and then altera like shot the
people that were gonna let us go through yeah that was real
that was ashley fucked up i was gonna have a rubber duckie
for the first time yeah you know that rubber duckie had it
coming no he didn't yeah no he can't come no he didn't no he
just wanted lemonade he just wanted lemonade that duck did
not walk up to the lemonade stand no he wanted grapes no he
watch the season finale.
Oh, sorry, bro.
Spoilers, bro.
Spoilers.
Yeah, what the fuck I was trying to do?
Slash spoilers, bro.
Sorry.
Oh, man.
Now you now how can you watch the finale?
Are they making more?
No, no.
It's the series finale.
You missed out the series finale, bro.
God damn it.
This is like worse than if someone's spoiled, bad for me.
I know, right?
This is fucked up.
Yeah, it's like how...
Yeah, I was about to watch the finale.
Now that's the point.
That was the point.
Now that...
Now that you know he wanted lemonade, what's the fuck is the
point in watching this series finale?
Well, it's about what drives him to want the lemonade.
You know what?
Fuck you.
You know, I don't care anymore.
Yeah, you were... You've been waiting for so long.
for him to finally maybe one day he'll finally want the
lemonade and then it just doesn't the payout is just not
doesn't feel the same now that you know it maybe we're
waiting for the character arc where he buys the lemonade
stand no now it's over the creator said he ain't making no
more no he's fully retired from the duck song he probably
made enough money yeah we should make a parody duck song do
it off broadway cashed out oh it's just yeah cash do it off
broadway of the That would go so fucking hard.
Oh, I got Lance's mixtape.
Lance's person.
Yeah, I got his mixtape.
Yeah, it's pink.
That's a good sell item.
Yeah.
Wait, I know.
Safe pocket.
Taking snow globe.
Wait, is that?
That costs a lot.
Yeah, check it out.
Check it out, Doki.
Yeah, yeah, check it out.
Yeah, I want to see.
Can I see?
Doki, Doki.
Let's keep moving, team.
Let's keep moving, guys.
keep moving guys wait chat which one's more expensive the
mixtape or the snow globe i think the snow globe is is it
how do you know i think it's the mixed tape i think you're
wrong where does where does it say oh i think you have to go
to inventory oh backing up why oh i'm stuck
mixtape was more expensive it's 10k it's 10k we can add a
snow globe back the snow globe is only 7k wait do you have a
safe pocket yes there's people close by thank you lock lock
in lock in okay okay we're locked in we're locked in we're
still locked in can you ping them i don't see them yet but
they're close don't worry no matter what if i die i like how
betto hasn't found a single and then Altair and I both have
been finding pink items.
I haven't found shit.
I haven't legendary.
I've got legendary and pink.
Wait, have you found pink items yet, Altair?
Uh, the snow globe was pink.
I found three pink items so far.
Wow.
Or four.
Yeah, we are siphoning Beto's luck.
We're taking all his luck.
Guys, there's someone on the bell tower.
On the bell.
Actually, okay.
He's headshot, I think.
I'm looking.
I don't have a scope on it.
Yeah, he was up here.
He probably went down the ladder.
Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, he's down there.
What?
I fell through the floor.
Are you kidding me?
Like a cross, you're saying?
Like, were I pinged?
That's where he was.
Are you talking?
Okay.
He went east side somewhere.
Yeah, I think he ran.
Man.
Bro, you fell?
I fell through the floor.
Bro.
I took all my health damage.
I know.
Bro.
yeah i'm going back down i don't want to be like you
interesting so oh my god yeah we're shooting arc i'm
shooting arc nice shot yeah i'm gonna go back down i'm
worried about falling down like him bro fell off i know bro
how the fuck unintentionally
Due to a glitch in the system, the glitch in the algorithm.
There's people down this way.
You want to head over there?
We can.
Oh?
What is it?
Oh, there's a ladder here.
Oh, that's how you go up.
Oh, shit.
I fell off.
Oh, guys.
It scared me.
Guys, we are...
Guys.
The boys and the masculine urge just to break our legs in a
fall.
and bleed out silently.
Yes, the masculine urge.
There's a guy in front of me.
Ping, ping, ping, ping, ping, ping.
He's in front of me.
Like, actually, it was just in front of me.
I got hit by my hand.
I don't know where in front of you.
But where's the other guy?
Where's the other guy?
Okay, chat race, chat race, or not.
Oh, my gosh, I'm getting shot too.
I can't see it.
Oh, I think I'm safe, yes.
I'm going to, it's just last guy, right?
Not sure.
I'm gonna say, I'm gonna rise, I'm gonna rise.
Okay.
Thank you.
To cover us.
That was one of the...
Because I know we res did another guy already.
I mean, we knocked him one.
Okay, I'm gonna check where the other guy went down.
Hello?
There's multiple.
That's stuff from him.
I don't know where I knocked him.
I'm going over the...
He's on me.
I'm looking.
I'm looking at the smoke, but I don't see anybody.
I'm watching.
Where did that guy go?
Oh no.
Oh!
Tree in front of me!
Tree!
Okay.
He's like prone or something.
You getting prone in this game?
No, no, no, no, no.
He's just...
He's hurt.
He's down.
Nice.
Probably one more.
Not me.
He's broken.
He's hit.
Nice, nice.
I'm gonna thirst this guy.
Oh, you're nice.
Yeah, yeah.
He's running.
Oh, you guys should meet up.
Any shields?
I have shields on me.
You guys need...
That guy had bandages.
We're good.
Thank you.
I'm just going to...
Is the drone coming up?
Yeah, I'm going to heal up fully then.
Good job, guys.
Yeah.
How are you dealing?
What am I hearing?
Is that the rocketeer?
I think that's...
Yeah, is that rocketeer?
Is it the drone or the rocketeer?
I can't tell.
I don't know where they is.
I can't see it.
Whatever that is.
Rocketeer, rocketeer, rocketeer.
Rocketeer, rocketeer.
What about that other person?
Did we kill that last guy?
No, he ran.
Yeah, he ran.
Did you guys loot them?
Yeah, I looted the one guy.
Is this the other guy we killed?
No.
There's two.
There's two down.
Is that the other guy?
Who wants to play this game a lot?
Why?
I just found a good blueprint that's like for the meta gun.
I think Altair will play more than me, right?
Are you sure?
You can have it.
Okay.
I'm here for the psychological warfare.
In that case, take this.
All right, Altair, take it.
Put it in your...
Oh, we just have a safe pocket.
Whoever has a safe pocket should have that.
I don't have a safe pocket.
I already use more in my safe pocket.
My other item has more money.
Is there some things...
I think you want that blueprint, but...
Where's the blueprint?
I put it on the ground.
I think Toki has it.
Oh, wait.
No, I don't.
It's on the ground.
Okay, here.
Thank you.
What do you guys get?
shot at while we're doing this.
Ooh.
Thanks, dude.
That's a good gun.
So you guys only looted one of them?
I don't know where the other guy died.
I think I looted two.
Wait, wait, go straight to our north?
Behind us, behind us, behind us.
Yeah, it's like this way.
Oh.
Where the shit?
Wait, wait, guys, guys.
Probe.
What's the probe?
What about this?
What is that?
Oh.
there's guys like here you're shooting the arcs yeah but
they're close if this thing sees me I got freak out oh my
god how the fuck you see you what is it okay it's gone it's
gone I see them I see these guys I'm looting I'm pulling my
gun up they were here They're not shooting the arcs though,
so...
Maybe they left, but...
I'd be surprised.
Huh.
Alright.
Yeah, they stopped shooting.
I guess we leave, right?
Yeah.
Fuck it.
Oh!
It's above us.
Shots.
Like this direction.
Yeah On my way.
I don't have much help though.
Um, I can give you bandages.
You're telling me.
I can give you bandages Give it a better.
Give it a better.
I split it Rocketeer.
Thank you I got band.
Oh, okay We're out.
Do you want it better?
I'm gonna have there's a rocketeer near us.
I'm running.
I'm trying to get the fuck away from it Yeah, rocketeers
next to us and rocketeers next to us wait I think we're safe
from it.
I would like to let Altair know that Doki did not fire a
single shot when him and Beto were fighting those two other
raiders.
I fired one shot.
No, I fired one shot.
One shot.
And then I said ping them, please.
And nobody here.
I split two bandages.
I was under a lot of pressure.
I couldn't ping right now.
I only saw one guy.
You guys are live.
I saw what I saw the one guy and I shot him and knocked him.
Also, Beto, there's another stack of bandages here.
What?
Thank you.
Man, thank you for covering me in battle when we were
fighting those guys.
See, I covered you guys.
Yeah, you shot so many bullets.
It's dark in here.
What?
Does that sound above us?
It's just a snitch.
Not a great luck.
What was the guy that ratted?
He just ran off.
We never got sick again.
No, no, no.
I'll tell you what was his name or her name.
I have no idea I'm going to watch the VOD replay You're
going to try to just find them Just to become an enemy of
them People are extracting up here Okay Okay, alright This
thing's okay He drops a loot Guys Dragoons time No, I'm
joking Use the power of the Dragoons Very wisely I'm joking
guys Don't do that this is personal i'll do it i'm gonna
comment i'm gonna comment on your channel with the timestamp
hey as a moderator this chat i went ahead and went with the
liberty of banning this guy off your chat you guys know
which okay guys okay okay this it was just a joke guys it
was just a joke we're on a weenie hunt we won't stop until
weed them out Wait.
I guess they could have left.
Don't hear anyone.
I'm scared of the arcs finding us.
Uh-oh.
I think they dipped.
Just snitch right behind us.
Oh, we getting out?
Oh, we can if you guys wanted to keep the loot.
Maybe you should.
Well, we have nine minutes until this is done.
Well, 13 minutes, you mean?
This one locks down in nine, yeah.
Oh, okay.
They close off at like different intervals.
You can try to see if anybody's climbing this tower and just
try to kill them when they come up.
Or do that.
Oof.
My, what a bad shot I am.
I hate these.
Snitches suck.
Yeah, they're snitches.
Oh, what was that?
What the fuck was that?
Oh, that's where it dropped.
Wait, are these?
It's a ball!
Oh, hornet.
Wait, I gotta kill the surveyor, I think.
We might, like, lure people over with it.
I hear another gunshot.
Like...
Yeah, I see them.
Where are they?
I'm gonna talk about this rock.
Okay.
I broke one.
You guys have a scopes on these things?
I have a sniper.
Oh, wait.
He's dead.
Bro.
What's the sniper called?
Is it just sniper?
It's called an osprey.
Oh, I see.
Oh, I broke him.
You gotta snitch above you.
There.
Way to snitch.
Yeah, I snitch the snitch.
Another one?
Bro, are you serious?
Bruh.
Oh my god.
He never dies.
Yeah, that's annoying.
I didn't even realize he was on me.
I don't see anybody else.
I do.
Heads up.
And the guy died.
Oh, recharge my shield.
to see oh my gosh can i hit that oh someone someone someone
up close up disappeared up close he's right here oh yeah
they just saw me they just saw me they're trying to talk to
me let's kill them
hey i didn't hear what they said what did they say they said
you're good oh right below over below we're not good are we
hello wait oh god they're talking to us i don't can't do
this again birthday to you it's michael's birthday over here
happy birthday to you happy birthday dear michael happy
birthday to you these guys are not fun thanks thanks thanks
guys It's his birthday, so we're trying to get him an
extraction.
Well, we can do that.
There's only game that he's played with Stardew Valley, so
he's pretty new to this stuff.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
This is his first day playing.
What if we, like, shoot them when we're at the extraction?
That's even... You want to do the most fucked up thing
possible.
Yeah, of course I do.
That should be how we end it.
That actually should be how we end it.
I'm not participating in this.
I'm putting my foot down.
I can't do it.
It's pointless.
Let's go to the extraction.
Is that the extraction?
I think it is down here.
How do we get there?
Not quite.
Hold on.
Uh-oh.
Wait, how do we set... Activate it?
There's a button.
I think it's being activated right now.
Oh, okay.
Do this thing.
Yeah, it's got opened up and they felt...
Guys, I have three grenades.
They could all go down there and I could just throw a bunch
of grenades on there.
I can't, dude.
I got my evil mind.
I can't do it.
You can't do it.
Beto, Beto, Beto, we're going.
Beto, this is it.
Happy birthday.
This is the one time you can do it.
On the ping.
You can do it right now.
Oh god.
Oh my god.
I can't.
I can't do it.
You had you madman.
You had to.
We were still in there too.
Yeah, but they're probably gone.
They're good.
They're fine.
No, I meant like, I think, did you kill anyone?
I don't know.
I don't think anyone died.
Did you get any kills?
Bro, you should have told me I would have shot the guy in
the face right after.
I can't.
You should have said.
It's good.
It's good that we did.
Bro, I would have shot.
I don't need anymore.
that i wish i shot him the moment you threw that grenade i
was waiting for the grenade oh wait wait check the check the
tab and see like how much damage you did yeah i will i will
don't worry i will all right it's open i don't know the fact
that you did end up throwing the grenade in the end it's
kind of up it's just the body down here be real sad you're
just as evil as me i might be worse by doing that especially
if there's a dead guy down here the thing is i know what i
am you pretend to have a conscience you are worse than me
you are worse than me Nobody died.
We did it!
Woohoo!
Yay!
Oh, check the tab.
Um...
Return home safely.
Brack's chief...
Did I not do any damage?
Wait, did you not do any damage?
I heard people break.
let's see oh damage raider i got a thousand xp for but i
don't know that's a lot of people around yeah i don't think
i did a whole lot to them level nine yeah oh i got both my
snow globe and the mix tape there you go a good run yeah i
got so much way i can expand my sash there you go yeah do i
just use it to expand sash or like is there anything let's
get with the money i find expanding the stash to be probably
the the most useful use of your your funds you can give your
money to me too no it's okay no it's okay man they were so
that was so fast how do i sell it how do i sell it better uh
right click right click uh and then you could sell oh oh yay
10 000 yay 7 000 yeah expando i'm rich ggs guys ggs that was
that was a fun session i had a good time with all of you
guys yeah good i wish we committed one more war crime in
that last game but like you know that was cute enough i
think we i think we had one shotgun so i couldn't do that
god say we were probably all gonna die you know they were so
nice i was like yeah we're trying to get and you have an
extraction for his birthday and then bam that's how you got
a bunch of stuff too yeah you got you caught up in rich
better we could have got rich in friendship that's what i
made today i'm glad you came out of this as friends that's
Yeah.
DGs, guys.
I have fun time.
Thank you, Fettel, for teaching us arc readers.
Of course.
I'm not the best teacher, but I'm glad you learned
something.
Yeah.
I learned how to be diabolical.
I learned how to...
No, she learned that on her own.
Yeah, yeah, that was...
I taught him about it.
That was not taught.
I taught Fettel new strategies in this game.
It was like my executioner.
Yeah.
Do you guys have anything that you guys want to chill before
we end stream?
Any projects or anything?
No?
Oh, buy my merch, I guess.
Buy my merch too.
Buy my merch.
If I have any for sale at the moment, that too.
Yeah.
You got the plushie.
I got my controller, my custom controller, guys.
Word Gaming.jp.
Yeah.
I will sponsor stream tomorrow, too.
Oh, yeah.
Tomorrow on Sunday.
I'd usually never stream on Sunday, but I got a sponsor.
Get that bag.
Yeah, be at 5 p.m., guys.
5 p.m.
PST.
Woo-hoo.
Yay!
All right, and buy our plushies.
Yeah, and my sweatshirt.
And my merch, too.
Buy all of it together in a bundle.
Buy both of it, yeah.
Yeah.
GG's.
guys it was fun it was fun let's do this again another time
yes either like manipulating or or like actually killing
them it doesn't matter yeah we'll have a theme we'll have a
theme it's good to have a plan yeah i don't know i feel like
the improvisation worked out more better you know it did it
did it did so how bloodthirsty battle actually is yeah i
think my favorite my favorite was definitely the birthday
strat oh that one was my favorite i feel like we could pull
that off like several times before it like well we could be
the richest people in the wasteland if i just removed my
yeah if you just remove no you're just pretending to have
the worst place like you're pretending to have a conscious
because you still did it you still i have a conscious you
know what that's true yeah i realized like i didn't really
have a conscious it was just that they gave me stuff in the
end so then i was like i do like free things so um but like
But like, that was fun.
The birthday show was just one of my favorite strategies
that we did.
Can we sing Betel Happy Birthday one more time?
Yeah.
Come to it.
Happy birthday to you.
Happy birthday, dear Betel.
I still want that.
3-0.
Thanks, guys.
Yay.
I'll catch you guys later.
Bye.
You guys have a wonderful day.
You too.
Bye.
Okay.
You guys siphon more luck from you.
Oh, God.
Yeah.
Oh, hello, everyone.
Um, that was really, really fun i love i love i love the
proximity chat guys i know everyone was like oh it's so fun
to be like don't shoot don't shoot and then start shooting
them but like we took it a whole nother level the role play
aspect was so fun like
and the role play aspect was so like i planted a whole life
story You were die.
It was very believable, though, wasn't it?
It was the Trojan cake.
It was...
I hope you have a terrible birthday.
Yeah.
That was the honey pie.
But, Toki, this is why I have trust issues.
Nia, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
it was it was definitely a fun time but anyway guys tomorrow
like i said we do have a sponsor stream tomorrow it is i
believe it's with chippy dokey um so we're doing another
sponsor stream tomorrow um i think i'm trying to remember um
i think it was where it was for a gacha game i'm trying i
can't remember the title sorry my mind has been super
frazzled lately so um it's all over
So that's why I'm like, I don't remember.
I have to check my messages again.
Because the last couple of days, I've been like not really
up to date with my message.
I mean, like always.
But like, you know, the last few days I've even been up to
date with like exactly what I'm doing.
Like what my work stuff is lately.
Because I'm so tired.
I was actually so tired for this stream before this stream.
Because I had to do like this meeting where I had to look
over this project.
And the project leader was like showing me like progress and
stuff.
I didn't really want to talk, but I had to join the call.
So, like, me and my manager joined the call of this project.
The project is being worked on to, like, they're guiding us
through, like, the stuff.
And then I was just typing to my manager, and he just spoke
for me, because I didn't want to talk at all, because I
wanted to save my talking stuff for this collab.
Because I was just like, I need, I'm so socially, the thing
is, I was so socially drained, that I was just like, okay, I
gotta save all my energy for today.
I gotta save all my energy for this collab today because I'm
so tired from, because I'm an introvert.
Like, my social battery is literally at critical.
I've just been charging it at 10% every day and then
draining it every day.
So, so, so it was like, I'm not, I'm not like, okay at the
moment because I'm so socially tired because I've done so
many claps back to back to back.
But, oh yeah, um, Metal Gear Solid might be delayed because,
um, um, I have to talk to Min about it, um, because, like,
uh, uh, Nexi said that she would prefer if it was in the
first week of December because she is traveling right now.
So, you know, I want to make sure, you know, she won the,
she won the charity auction.
I want her to make sure that, you know, she'll be there to
actually watch the stream since she was the one that
requested the game.
So that's why I'm just going to be talking to men and seeing
what her schedule is like.
And if she is free for the stream on the first week of
December.
So we'll see about that.
Anyway, guys, I'm going to head off now.
As always, everybody.
Stay hydrated.
Posture check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flow.
If you stay up for me, head to bed because you deserve it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Guys, I'm not...
that evil.
I do it for content, guys.
And as long as I repent, it's fine.
All is forgiven.
As long as I repent at the end, before I die and be like,
I'm sorry.
All will be forgiven.
Like, I'm going to hell.
Yeah.
Anyway, anyway, I'll see.
Guys, it's boring when you play nice all the time.
Thank you, everyone.
Bye-bye, guys.
Bye.